- Every time I have a Kit
Kat, it's usually like,
it's usually in like, you know,
like two Kit Kats together,
right?
- Yeah.
And you split it, and you eat it one at-
- No, I literally just grab, and just-
(snack crunching)
Do this.
- Don't be, (sighs)
oh God.
(baby crying)
(relaxed music)
Hello, and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste".
I am boy, and with me today are boys.
- Hello, it's me.
(man laughs)
- The usual.
- Yay.
- How are you doing boys?
- I'm doing well, boy.
I am tired.
- We're not doing this,
are we?
(Gigguk laughs)
- Lad.
- I'm doing fine.
- You're doing fine?
- I'm tired as all hell.
- Yeah, you've just
been building a fuck ton
of furniture, haven't you?
- I've just been
building furniture for the past week.
- You've just been going
through the entire Ikea catalog,
and just been building that-
- Yeah, pretty much.
It's like never, it's just like...
Am I in a respawn point
for Ikea furniture?
Because every time I build one,
another one just respawns the next day.
I'm like, "cool".
- What's been the most satisfying build?
Wait, what is the most
annoying furniture to build
in general?
- Ikea.
Anything from Ikea.
- Sometimes it's good, though.
Well okay, what's the item
that is always most annoying?
I have my own thoughts on this.
I've already decided.
- I don't know.
Maybe, I mean I've built
desks, shelves, chairs, tables.
- I've built everything. (laughs)
- You name it, I've built it. (laughs)
- You name it-
- Well,
what was your answer, Connor?
Since you seem to-
- All right, listen.
Okay, so-
- Shit.
- Oh shit.
- It's okay.
It's a little spill.
Beds can be annoying, right?
Beds can be quite frustrating.
If you get the really
cheap beds, beds are shit.
They're either like a 2x2 Rubik's Cube,
or a 64x64 Gauntlet Cube.
- You know what you need
to get, what we got?
A Koala bed.
- Is it a shout out, Joey?
- Are you being sponsored
by Koala Beds right now?
- No, no.
- Oh yeah,
because I will say, I did
sleep on Chris's couch-
- Actually, can we get some
tissue please? (laughing)
- Oh yeah, yeah, can we wipe this off?
- All right.
- Because Chris has like-
- A couch.
- A sofa bed, right?
- I think, by them.
Yeah, and I was like, "Chris's
sofa is nicer than my bed".
(Joey giggles)
- Yeah, because I remember
when we just moved here,
I just bought whatever
was the cheapest option
on Amazon.
- Biggest mistake. (laughs)
- And now I regret it,
because at that time,
it's like, whenever you
move into a new place,
the most difficult part is just,
the amount of upfront money you put down.
You look at your bank
account, and you're just like.
(sighs) Oh, that's a really low number.
And that's a really big
number I'm giving away,
all at once, right?
- Like, do I really need a microwave?
I'm sure I can just slap
my chicken hot, you know.
- Yeah, yeah, just rub
it across the ground.
Friction will warm it up.
- It's whatever.
Like, I'll survive.
And I'm finally getting
rid of my laundry machine,
my washing machine.
- Yeah, we're getting rid
of ours as well.
- I got rid of
my cockroach infested one.
- (laughs) Oh yeah, that one.
- Oh, you still have that one?
- Yeah, I still have that one.
- Okay. (laughs)
- He cleaned it up though,
he cleaned it up, right?
- I did clean it up.
But you know, I mean, I don't
know what's been in there.
So it is nice to get rid
of it, get a new one.
- Get something nice.
You can afford it.
- I'm taking the old one
from this studio. (laughs)
- Are you?
- Yeah! (laughs)
- Wait, what?
- Are you actually? (laughs)
- Yeah, because we have to get rid of it.
And I was like, "Well I'll take it".
Because it's better than the one I have.
- Wait, are you actually taking ours?
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is the first I'm hearing about it.
- Yeah.
- Well, wait,
what did you think was
gonna happen with it?
- I thought we were just
gonna get rid of it.
- I was gonna get rid of it.
- No, why would you do that?
I'll just take it.
- Well, no.
Because if you go to like,
Big Camera or Yodobashi,
and if you buy a fridge from there,
they have a free service where
if you have a fridge already,
they'll get rid of the old one for you.
- Yeah but-
- So I was just
gonna utilize that.
- What?
- To get rid of my fridge.
- Yeah, have you, so why do
you still have your old fridge?
I thought you bought a new one?
- No, no, no, no, my washing
machine, washing machine.
- Oh, washing machine.
- Okay, okay, okay, if you
buy a new fridge on Amazon,
there's a service-
- That's what I did.
- Okay, they'll take the old one away.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah-
- You can do that
with your fridge as well.
- It's not my fridge.
- Wait, wait-
- How did it take you
so god damn long to get some tissues?
(men laughing)
Why'd it take two of you? (laughing)
- (laughing) We literally asked
for this five minutes ago.
- I just saw a SWAT team sting operation.
- I just watched a SWAT (laughs)-
- What a chaotic start-
- I just saw Ashley
come in, doing like the John
Travolta, like, huh? (laughs)
- We have two staff,
and it took both of them
five minutes to get some
tissues in the other room.
- Wait, wait, wait, hold
on, hold on, can we go back-
- We got very confused-
- Can we go back
to the whole fridge thing?
So wait-
- I got rid of my fridge,
by doing that service
where I bought a new one,
and I asked them to get rid of it.
But-
- Wait.
But did you say you were
gonna take our fridge?
- No, I'm taking our washing machine.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh, washing machine.
- Yeah, okay so-
- Oh, I thought you
were gonna take my fridge from my house-
(Garnt laughing)
- No. (laughs)
How would I do that, Joey?
- And I'm like, "When did we decide this?"
(Garnt laughing)
- Explain to me the logistics.
Think Joey! (laughs)
- I was like, "Did this
man really just be like,
'So yeah, I'm taking your fridge.
I decided, I'm taking your fridge'".
- I'm taking a page out
of my ancestors' books,
and just taking things
from other people's houses.
- I thought you were taking
the fridge from the studio.
- No, no, no, no, no.
I already have a, you guys
know I have a new fridge!
- I know you, that's why
I was so fucking confused-
- Why would I get a new fridge?
- You have to be specific.
- What the fuck?
I literally just got this fridge!
It's a great fridge, great
color, great everything,
ergonomics, fantastic.
- Because I, this is the
first time I'm hearing
about you getting a new fridge.
So that's why-
- Oh no.
I'm not getting a new fridge.
- Oh my God.
- I already have
a new fridge, I'm, so-
- When did you buy the fridge?
- Like four months ago! (laughs)
- Wait-
- You've been to my house!
- The cockroach one?
- You've seen it.
Yeah, but I also, okay remember-
- You just said you, I swear to God,
literally five minutes ago, you just said,
"I still got the cockroach fridge".
- I have the laundry machine.
The cockroach laundry machine, I have.
- Wait, but you had a
cockroach laundry machine-
- Laundry machine?
- What the fuck!
(men laughing)
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait-
- The only story we heard-
- Wait, wait, I've only heard
about the cockroach fridge machine.
You have a cockroach
laundry machine as well?
- Okay so, when I got my fridge,
it was a two for one deal.
You know, so.
- Yeah no,
I know about that.
- Oh okay, so they both
had cockroaches in them.
- Yeah.
- Well, no.
But they were in the same building.
- No, no, no, no, no, you
said your washing machine
also had cockroaches in it.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- There might have been
one or two in there, I can't remember.
- Mudon, rewind the clip right now.
- I speak to someone on
Craigslist, I found a fridge
and a laundry machine,
what do you call that?
- A washing machine?
- Washing machine. (laughs)
- I don't fucking know.
- A laundry machine.
- It's what it is, right?
(Joey laughing)
They both came here in the same truck,
they both came from the same place.
Frankly, if your fridge had,
you know, there was a
good 15, 20 cockroaches
in this fridge.
- Right.
- I'm not, you know, at that point,
I'm not giving you the
benefit of the doubt
with any of your other appliances.
Like, how can you live with
that many, this was vile.
This was actually vile.
- Yeah, I don't understand
some people-
(Garnt stuttering)
- How big were the cockroaches?
Because I've never seen
cockroaches in Japan.
- Cockroaches in Japan-
- Thus far.
- There was like one or two
that were pretty big chonkers.
But a lot of them were
the little baby ones.
But like, the worst part was,
and this is very much a gross warning.
I've never spoken about this before,
but when I ripped off
all the felt and stuff,
and there was a hole in the felt,
and I put it in a fucking bleach,
I know that doesn't kill them.
But I just wanted to
bleach the fridge stuff-
- How did you kill them?
- Most of them were already dead.
- Oh, okay.
- There were so many
dead cockroaches inside of this fridge.
Yeah, yikes, it's pretty disgusting.
(Joey groans)
And I paid for that!
I paid for that!
(Joey sighs)
Can't believe that.
- That's what you get, man.
For using-
- Craigslist.
- Never again.
You know, it was the one
time where I was like,
"I'll give Craigslist a chance".
(Joey laughs)
I tried it-
- Because have you ever
dealt with cockroaches in the UK at all?
Because I remember for most of my life,
I had just never seen a cockroach.
Because the UK's pretty
clean, in terms of-
- Imagine the privilege of
living in a sanitary home.
(men laugh)
Cockroaches, what is that?
- I saw a fair amount
when I moved to London.
- Oh really?
- In Wales I didn't see many.
- Yeah, because I remember
my very first cockroach experience
was actually not in the UK,
but it was in Thailand, right?
And I remember, because my
house is not in the city center.
It's like, right on the outskirts.
And we're near a lot of, not a forest,
but a lot of grassland, basically.
So we're like, right out in
the outskirts of the city.
So we're like, right
next to nature as well.
So, some of the cockroaches
we'd find are pretty massive.
Right, and at this point,
I was living in Thailand
with Sydney, and it was just me and Sydney
in the house, right.
And so, I was just
sitting in my living room,
just chilling out.
And I hear this fucking guttural scream,
coming from Sydney, right? (laughs)
She's like, I had never
heard Sydney scream,
like Sydney's already
a loud person as it is.
But I, no, no, but I had never heard
this kind of scream from Sydney.
I was just like, I thought
she had just witnessed
a fucking murder or something, right?
That's the kind of scream-
- She's reading a dojin,
or it's murder. (laughs)
- Yeah, so I come rushing over,
thinking that something serious,
something bad has happened.
And I just see this
fucking massive cockroach,
just chilling in our kitchen floor.
- Well yeah, how big are we talking?
- Okay, so it was about that bit.
(Connor shudders)
- Okay, yeah, yeah-
- It was a chonky motherfucker-
- How much bigger does it need to get
before it starts fucking talking?
- (laughs) That's the point.
- Terraform machine-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because the way the cockroaches get in,
because our kitchen is pretty clean,
but because we're right on the outskirts,
right near the forest an everything.
So sometimes they can crawl up the drains,
and come out from under the drains-
- Oh no.
- I didn't know this.
I only found out about this afterwards.
Because my first thought was,
"Fuck, I thought our kitchen was clean!
Fucking burn the entire house
down", and everything, right?
But this was my first time.
- It's like a stealth mission.
It's like Solid Snake.
- Dun, dun, dun, dun.
- And like, I don't know
how you guys are with bugs.
I'm sure you're fine, Joey,
because you're Australian.
For me, I'm not a massive fan of bugs.
- No, I don't enjoy-
- I mean, I'm not a fan!
- I'm not a fan of
having to deal with them.
But some people can just
like, fucking grab the bugs,
or whatever, I'm just like, no.
I'll do like, the cup method,
where you see a spider,
you cup it, and you put a piece of-
- Paper in it-
- Paper in it,
and let it out, I don't enjoy it.
I'm not like, scared, but
I don't enjoy doing it.
- It's not a fun process.
- I don't really, when
there's people who like,
fucking grab the spiders, and are like,
"Oh what do you mean you're scared of it?"
I don't wanna fucking grab the spider.
Why would I wanna grab the spider?
Even if I don't like, hate this thing,
why the fuck would I wanna
have it wriggling around
in my hand?
- Exactly.
(Garnt laughs)
- Why do you do this?
- That's the Aussie in you.
- What people do this shit?
It's like, they think they're
motherfucking Bear Grylls,
because they manage to catch
a house spider in their hand-
- I mean-
- I don't give a fuck!
I just don't wanna touch that shit.
- Have I told you of the
method that my dad uses
to get rid of cockroaches?
- We'll do that afterwards.
- What, he just fucking
sucks it in his mouth?
(Garnt laughs)
Oh, what do you mean,
you don't have a spider in
your mouth, son? (blows)
- Well yeah, because me
and Sydney are a couple.
Because she's, I feel like
when you're in a couple,
the one who's least scared
is the one who deals with-
- Of course, of course.
- And of course,
it was me, I wasn't happy about it.
But I was just like,
"Sydney, you look like
you just witnessed a murder, whatever.
Get out of the way, I guess, as the man"-
- Let the man handle-
- I guess,
as the man of the house
here, I will take care
of the cockroach.
- I know how to do it.
- (laughs) And I was thinking,
this was going to be easy,
right, the cockroach was big, you know.
And I didn't know that much
about cockroaches at the time.
- Oh, how naive you were.
- Yeah.
Oh how naive I was.
So I thought, this was gonna be an easy,
because we had literally,
we had a cockroach spray.
And I was thinking, all I
need to do is get the spray,
spray the cockroach, job done, it dies,
I sweep it out the house.
Easy, right.
Now, so I get the spray,
and there are two pieces
of information that I didn't
know about cockroaches
before I did this.
Number one, cockroaches are
very, very hard to kill.
(laughs) And I knew this.
But I thought, it's a spray
designed to kill cockroaches.
Therefore, in my mind, instant death.
You know, that's how it's
worked my entire life.
Right, number two, cockroaches can fly.
I did not know this either. (laughs)
- Is that some species, or all of them?
- I think all of them can fly.
- I've never seen a cockroach fly.
- They have to be pretty
fucking, GTFO mode,
to start flying around.
- So I did not know
they could fly either,
so it was just like,
crawling around on the floor.
- They're really terraformers.
- Oh yeah, it's literally terraformers.
- It's like literally, last
resort for those cockroaches.
- Yeah, so I'm just like,
"Sydney, get out of the way".
Let the man of the house handle this.
And so, I get the spray
out, get pretty close to it,
and I just give it a nice
little love tap with the spray.
- Oh no.
- No, no, no.
- (laughs) And what happens?
It starts freaking the fuck out, right?
I'm just like, "Yo, yo, yo,
what the fuck is happening?"
Right, and then I spray it even more.
And then I just hear the,
(imitates wings buzzing).
You know the sound where you
just hear the wings flapping?
And then it starts
flapping, and then it flies,
and lands on my chest.
(men laugh)
And then-
- It's like, counterattack.
- Yeah, (laughs) and then
I'm in fucking flight or,
fight or flight mode now.
And then I fucking scream,
as loud as I've screamed
in my life before, I think.
(Joey giggles)
(laughs) I'm not ashamed to admit
how fucking loud I
screamed, five minutes after
I've just told Sydney,
"You're a fucking pussy,
let me handle this". (laughing)
I brush it off, like I fucking
leg it out of the kitchen.
And then I just lock the kitchen, right?
And I could hear the
cockroach is just freaking out
in the kitchen, all I hear is just like,
(imitating buzzing wings).
- You're like, "Sydney get
out, it's his house now.
It's his house, we gotta leave!
We gotta get our stuff!"
- And Sydney just turns around and goes,
"Did you do it?
What's going on?"
And I'm just like, "Just
don't go in that kitchen".
(men laugh)
And like, me and Sydney were just like,
in the living room, we could
just hear this cockroach
for the entire night, just freaking out.
- Oh God.
- And we were just like,
"Oh God, are we gonna have to
burn the entire house down?"
- It'll get bored eventually.
- Yeah, it'll get bored eventually.
- Cockroach spray is the biggest
fucking lie on the planet.
Aren't cockroaches the only animals
that can survive a nuclear blast?
- I don't know-
- Something like that.
So it's like, what is in these sprays
that is supposedly stronger
than a nuclear blast? (laughs)
- That's why I don't stop
until it stops moving.
I'm like "Apex" aim, 100%,
(imitating can spraying)
just following it around the room.
- Yeah, I thought that
would be fine as well.
Like I said, I didn't know they could fly.
That was the big, "Oh, they could fly".
The rules of the game have changed now.
They can counterattack you now.
- Normally I spray them,
just so they're stunned
for a second, so I can fucking smack 'em.
- Oh, well I mean, I
don't like doing that,
because then it leaves a mark.
And also, it's not a guaranteed kill.
Unless you're using a fucking heavy boot-
- Joey, what's your KDA with cockroaches-
- You grab a suit shoe, right?
Because the sole of the suit
shoes are very firm, very flat.
You can just like, fucking-
(hand punches table)
clap 'em on the-
- Oh yeah, I mean the way my dad-
- This is a weird conversation-
- Is even hardcore.
- He just fucking eats it.
He's Australian, it's free food.
- So, in our household, we already know,
cockroach spray is a lie.
So just don't even use the spray.
- Cockroach sprays are a lie.
- It never kills the cockroach in one go.
- Yeah, just smack 'em
with the spray. (laughs)
- Or, you do what my dad
does, which is, in Australia,
because we also have big fuck
off cockroaches like that.
All right, and there was one
that appeared in the kitchen.
What, it's always the kitchen.
And it appeared in the
kitchen, my mum screams.
My dad walks in, he's like, "What is it?"
She points to the wall,
and there's a big fuck
off cockroach like that.
And he's like, "Son." (laughs)
- Eat it, eat it.
- He calls me over, "Yes
father, what is it?"
It's like, "Son, bring me two tissues".
(Garnt laughs)
And I was like, "I beg your pardon?"
He's like, "Bring me two tissues".
- One-ply, I wanna feel it.
- I'm like, "Just two?"
He's like, "Just two".
I'm like, "All right".
I bring him two tissues, and he's like,
"Place it on my hand".
So I place it flat on his
hand, one on top to the other.
And he's like, he dead ass
looks at me, and he goes,
"Watch this". (laughs)
He goes up to the wall,
and I've never seen a man
move this fast in my life.
It was like, bap!
And just grabs him, and it's in his hand!
Like, in the blink of an eye.
He just fucking, bap!
He just grabs it in his hand,
and you can hear this thing,
just (imitating buzzing wings)
like, around in his hand.
- Did he do the obligatory anime crush?
- No, he walks up to my mom,
and goes right up to her
ear and goes, crunch!
- Oh no.
- And then he looks me in
the eyes, and he's like,
"I love that sound".
(men laughs)
I'm like, "You are the most"-
- Your fucking house is like-
- "You are the most Australian
father I could ever have,
and I love it".
- It's just like,
the weirdest fucking house on earth.
- I think I was like, eight
years old when he did that.
And I was like, "My dad is
the strongest in the world".
(men laugh)
That was the moment where
I'm like, "Don't fuck with"-
- Like, that's how to assert dominance
in your family, right.
- You're introducing
the anime villain.
- Yeah, it's like,
if you're in the playground,
you're making fun
of each other's dad's, or
you're trying to one up
each other's dad's, don't say,
"Oh no, my dad's the
president of Nintendo".
No, "My dad grabs cockroaches by hand
and crushes them to death".
- My dad could beat up your dad.
Well, my dad fucking-
- Hand grabs cockroaches.
(men laugh)
And they're like, "All right, never mind".
(Garnt laughs)
"Your dad's number one".
- Fucking like, some
kung fu, where it's just-
- I've never seen, because
I thought, I was like,
"Is this guy really gonna
catch this cockroach by hand?"
Because we all know how fast cockroach-
- You're literally, you
would literally speed wagon
watching, like commentating-
- It was, yeah.
It was actually amazing.
- I'm amazed by his
sheer agility. (laughs)
- But I feel like, my dad
is like, I don't know.
When it comes to insects for some reason,
he's weirdly really lucky, I guess.
Or, I don't know what the right word-
- Lucky?
- Okay, he told me this story,
of one time he was out in the back yard,
and he was with his brother, my uncle.
And obviously, if you're barbecuing out
in the summer or whatever, in Australia,
there's a fuck load of
flies everywhere, right?
But you just, you know,
fucking brush 'em off.
It's whatever.
And my dad, he was I don't
know, teenage or something,
and he had a knife in his hand,
just a regular steak knife,
and he just had it in his hand.
And he saw a fly on the table.
And he just went-
(hand slams table)
And he cut the fly's head cleanly in half.
And he just kind of
stood there and was like-
- Your dad's a psychopath.
- I can't believe
I just did that. (laughs)
- That's like some fucking Nen shit, man.
That's like, what's the
anime move where you can
completely remove your presence, right?
- His dad just pulled that shit.
(Garnt laughs)
- He appeared right behind
me, and I didn't notice him!
(men laugh)
- Because like, I have
never successfully caught
or swatted a housefly in my life.
- Have you ever successfully
smacked a mosquito
in your hand?
- Mosquito, yeah.
- Really?
- Mosquitoes like, they're
annoying, but it's doable.
Fly, it's like they have
observation hacking.
They know what's coming five seconds
before it comes, you know-
- It's like Goku versus Frieza.
It's just like, teleporting
all over. (laughs)
- Can't they like, avoid
bullets or something?
Because of the way that they like-
- Flies?
- Yeah, because when you,
when something goes near
them, the air pressure,
they use it to get away.
- Oh, really?
- To like, dodge.
Yeah, it's really interesting.
- I don't know.
I've never-
- I swear I saw
a YouTube video of someone
shooting a fly with a gun.
- How can you fucking shoot,
a fly isn't a massive target anyway.
- Best marksman versus best fly?
YouTube series, I don't know.
- Marksman versus fly.
- I guess, I mean-
- Sounds like a scene
from an anime, right-
- I don't know
if this is like, a fucking fever dream.
I feel like, did I actually see this?
I feel like I've seen this-
- Remember that one episode
of "Golgo 13", where he
snipes a fly? (laughs)
- Right. (laughs)
- I feel like
90% of the YouTube recommended, I'm like,
"Did I actually watch that?"
(Joey laughs)
I feel like I 1/4th remember
a bunch of facts and stories.
I'm like, "This one time
where this guy did a thing,
but I don't really know".
- [Garnt] (laughs) I don't really know.
- He did a thing, and was
impressive, I don't know.
- Something about a cube,
like you know, I don't know.
- A cube? (laughs)
- Something about a cube,
or something.
Wait so, wait, what is
the worst furniture?
Because I was saying beds are terrible.
I know we're going way back-
- Yeah, we're going way back.
You never finished it, but-
- Okay.
Beds are terrible, but
I think coffee tables,
somehow, these small things can sometimes
be the worst fucking things on earth,
because they're like,
"Let's make coffee tables
the most secure thing ever in existence".
- Out of all the things I've built,
so for the past week I've built chairs,
I've built coffee tables,
cabinets, all that kind of shit.
The worst one by far was the Ikea chairs.
And they're like, it's like four pieces.
And they just over complicate
the fuck out of it,
for no reason.
- Yeah, actually,
the worst one I built were
my table and chair set.
And that's because when I built it,
followed the exact instructions.
And you think, you screw it tight,
it'll just work perfectly, it's a chair.
Right, and literally every
chair fucking wobbled.
Right, it was just uneven.
And I spent an entire day having to
perfectly unscrew these screws
so that the chairs will balance.
And I'm just like, "Why can't
you just balance it normally?"
It's a chair!
It's literally, it should
just be same length,
all four chairs, no.
It wasn't the case.
That's why it was a
fucking nightmare for me.
- That's just like, a dick
move on the designers though.
Right, they were just like,
"I'm a fuck with this guy.
The next guy who buys my chair".
- Yeah.
(Connor gags)
But like, yeah.
I was like, I also agree
with you about the bed.
I didn't wanna build my bed so much,
that I just never got a bed! (laughs)
- Wait, what are you sleeping on?
- I sleep on-
- Just a mattress?
- Yeah, just a mattress.
- What? (laughs)
Wait, so you don't have
a bed frame at home?
- No.
(Joey laughs)
I actually, because, I
actually like it, right.
- You can get those like, you can (laughs)
that's so ghetto!
You can get the fucking, the low frames.
The ones that are literally on the floor.
- Isn't it also really bad for your floor,
to just have a mattress on it?
- Is it?
- Doesn't it get moldy,
or whatever?
- Dear God-
- Isn't that
the whole reason-
- Have you looked
underneath your mattress?
- Isn't that the whole reason
for a bed frame, is to stop
the floor from molding,
or something?
- Can one of you
Google this?
- We do have like,
a bed frame, but it's
one of those literally,
floor bed frames, where it's like-
- It's just a plank of wood on the-
- Yeah, so it's basically
just a plank of wood
on the floor.
- That's what I was saying.
You can get the floor bed-
- Yeah, and the reason for it
was because when we moved in,
we slept on a futon at
Connor's for like a week.
And at first, "Sydney was just like,
why would we sleep on the floor?
Peasants sleep on the floor".
And me, being the Asian,
every time I go to Thailand,
I'd always sleep on the floor
at my Grandma's place, and I'm just like,
there's something comforting
about sleeping on the floor.
I don't know what it is, but I sleep,
I just realized that
whenever we go to onsens,
or ryokans or whatever, you'd
sleep on the futon floors,
it's futon mattresses.
And you just get the best night of sleep
you have in your life, and I don't know-
- I think it might be because the tatami,
or the floor, whatever
it is you're sleeping on,
the hard surface, it
flattens your back out.
So I guess that just naturally
gives you better sleep or something.
But I agree, I get the
best sleep in a futon.
- Yeah, so we just decided,
why not just fucking sleep on the floor?
We just got a mattress-
- But then you miss out
on the, you know when you wake up,
and you're like, "Oh fuck".
Then you just kind of sit on the bed,
with your legs on the floor?
And you're just like,
"Fuck, I gotta get up".
But you're not fully awake-
- Do you love that feeling? (laughs)
- Yeah, I kind of like that.
- I hate that feeling.
- Because I don't wanna
get out of bed right away.
But I wanna kind of get
up, and I wanna put my,
you know, I wanna try to get ready,
or hype myself up to-
- Oh, for me,
there's only two states.
There's lying in the bed on my phone,
or just out of bed.
- What, you never sit there
at the edge of the bed, being like, "Fuck.
I've gotta get up"-
- No, I kind of realized
that I wanna spend the
least time in my bed room
as physically possible, right?
And I feel like you get
a better night's sleep
if your bed room is just for sleeping.
Because I remember at my old place,
especially when I started YouTube,
and we were working literally
with my bed next to me,
I would get the worst
night's sleep, every time-
- I 100% agree, yeah.
- I could not,
I could not go in my bed
room, and just go on my bed,
and just go into sleep mode.
Like, I've found that once I positioned it
so I would spend the least
time in my bed as possible,
I would get much better sleeps.
- Yeah, my place, two places ago now,
was yeah, it was the same.
Like, you guys have been there before.
The tiny apartment I had?
- The fucking tiny apartment.
- The tiny apartment-
- With the Anime Man couch,
with all the plushies.
(Joey laughs)
- Well, when I was like, 18,
I probably would have thought
that was a cool ass apartment.
- No, when I first moved in,
it was a cool ass apartment-
- When you get older, you're like,
"Oh, small"-
- But then I very quickly
realized that if your where you work
is in the same room, or
next to where you sleep,
you get the worst sleep, and
you get the worst productive.
Like, the worst productivity.
You just can't do anything.
Because it's just like,
"I could just turn over,
and literally walk half a meter,
and just sleep if I wanted to".
Like, how can you concentrate
in a room like that?
- [Garnt] Yeah. (laughs)
- I feel like there's
parts where I enjoyed it.
I like the fact that I
can just turn my monitor
towards my bed and just watch shit.
Because sometimes
watching stuff on the TV,
it's really a pain in the ass.
Because like, you know, on the PC,
you can just get the website up,
and then you can throw it
on the monitor, it's easy.
On a TV, you've gotta fuck
around with Chromecast shit.
You gotta figure, "Oh,
which apps work for my TV,
which don't", you know.
And a PC, it's like-
- I mean, it's not,
it's not that much-
- It's like five more minutes
worth of work that I don't want.
And also, I used to have a
setup that I really liked,
where I had like a, next
to my bed I had a keyboard
with a track pad on it.
So I would just fucking,
apply to shit in my bed,
and then change the-
- Pretty sure that's
how people get bed ridden.
- I think I was like, getting there.
I was trial running.
I mean, if I was ever bed ridden,
at least I know the system.
- At least I can work.
- Yeah, I had it all set up, you know.
It was a good system-
- Jesus Christ.
- No, but like, I feel like,
especially when I get out
of bed, I'm just like, way more awake.
The problem isn't-
- Typically, when I'm
out of my bed, I'm awake.
- Yeah, yeah.
The problem isn't that, the problem is-
(men laughing)
Getting out of the bed
in the first place.
- Yeah, true, true.
- Like, having my legs
hang off or whatever,
that's not gonna help me. (laughs)
- Sometimes the foot out
of the bed, free hanging,
is a pretty good feeling though.
- I still haven't figured out a way
to get out of bed when
it's a cold winter's day,
or a cold winter morning-
- Yeah, yeah.
That's why like, I'm kind
of glad now, that I moved.
Because it's starting to get warm-
- Thank God-
- It's a lot easier now
to just immediately get out of bed.
Because the inside of your mattress,
and the outside of your mattress
is pretty much the same temperature.
So it's not a fucking struggle,
like it is in the winter.
But yeah, to this day, I've
been trying to figure out,
how the fuck do I get
out of bed in winter?
How do I remove the 10 Gs
of force that is created
in the wintertime, in my bed?
Because yeah, every
time, I always do the...
The one thing I found out is like,
okay, one limb at a time.
It's like, stick one
arm out, get that like,
to room temperature, all right.
And then get the next limb
out, and then it's just like,
a slow process, right,
it's like slow loading.
- It's like, you know, when you're going
in the swimming pool for the first time.
And it's a really cold pool.
Is it like, do you jump in straightaway,
or would you go one limb at a time?
- I jump in straightaway.
- Jump in straightaway.
- Yeah, because that's how I feel,
whenever I need to get out of bed
on a cold winter's night.
- You just gotta chug a fuck ton of water
when you wake up.
That shit wakes you up.
You tried that-
- Oh yeah.
- Just get a full bottle of water.
When you wake up, just down it-
- But I can chug a full bottle
of water in bed. (laughs)
- There is no way you can lie back down
after chugging a full bottle of water.
- Oh, I 100%-
- Wait, wait.
Why does that work?
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN!
- [Connor] A few decades ago,
private citizens used to
be largely that, private.
What changed? The internet.
Think about everything you've browsed,
searched for, watched, or tweeted.
Now imagine all that data
being crawled through,
collected, and aggregated by third-parties
into a permanent, public record.
Your record!
Having a private life,
exposed for others to see
was once something only
celebrities worried about.
But in the era where everyone is online,
everyone is a public figure.
To keep my data private, when I go online,
I turn to ExpressVPN.
- [Joey] Did you know there are hundreds
of data brokers out
there whose sole business
is to buy and sell your data?
The worst part is they
don't have to tell you
who they're selling it
to, or get your consent.
- No consent, in 2021?
One of these data points
is your I.P. address.
Data harvesters use your
I.P. to uniquely identify you
and your location, but you know what,
with ExpressVPN, my
connection gets rerouted
through an encrypted server,
and my I.P. is masked.
- [Connor] Every time
I turn ExpressVPN on,
I'm given a random I.P. address,
shared by other ExpressVPN customers.
That makes it more
difficult for third-parties
to identify me and harvest my data.
And the best part is, is how
easy ExpressVPN is to use.
No matter what device you're on,
phone, laptop, or smart
TV, all you have to do
is have one button to get protected.
- So if, like me,
you believe that your
data is your business,
secure yourself with
the number one rated VPN
on the market, visit
expressvpn.com/trashtaste
and get three extra months for free.
That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S-V-P-N
dot come, slash "Trash Taste".
Go to expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to learn more.
- Back to the episode.
- Baby.
- Listen, I don't understand
the rules of hydration, Garnt.
All I know is that semi
waterboarding your organs
wakes you up.
- (laughs) It puts your
(mumbles), it's like, ah!
- It does!
You know, my organs are sleeping,
and it's like, "Oh God, we're drowning!
Oh, Jesus", and wakes up.
And, you're also hydrated,
so it's a win-win.
- No, no, I do that.
The first thing I do when I get out,
is take a piss, and then
drink a shit load of water.
- I drink enough fucking water as it is.
- I hate morning pees, man.
Morning pees suck.
Because it's always really strong, too.
Because you're dehydrated.
- It's always froth as fuck.
- Mine isn't frothy, but-
(Joey laughs)
Morning pees just suck, I
hate peeing in the morning.
Because it also-
- Mine's the complete opposite.
- Also, it just hurts.
Does-
- A little bit.
- Because also, no wait, wait.
Don't make a face, yeah-
- Because it's thick.
- Yeah, but-
- What, what?
- Because, because you've
been holding it in all night.
You know what I mean?
So, you wake up, and you're like,
"Oh, I really need to piss".
But I'm also like, "I
really wanna stay in bed".
And then, the only, most the time,
if I don't chug the water,
the thing that gets me up
is the uncomfort of needing to piss
is stronger than my want
to stay in this bed.
- Yeah, yeah, I think it hurts, because-
- It's supply and demand.
- It's like doing your first
lift in the gym, right?
It always hurts.
(Garnt laughs)
Right, the bladder is like,
"I haven't done anything
all day"-
- You're stalling
like a man who doesn't
go to the gym. (laughing)
And it's like the first-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah-
- It's like that.
No, because your bladder
hasn't been moving all night.
And then suddenly, it has to move.
So it's like, "All
right, fuck, let's do it.
Ah!" (laughs)
- I don't know, I always like,
mine are always just like,
comes out easily, but I
think that's just because
I drink a fuck ton of
water before I go to bed.
- How do you not get up, do you not get up
in the middle of the night to pee?
- I just find that the time it takes
for the water to get in, is
the perfect amount of time
for me to sleep-
- (laughs) It's just like,
optimized.
- It's just like,
natural, it's just a natural (mumbles).
- I feel like in the past two years,
before two years ago, I
never, ever woke up to pee.
Ever, and then suddenly
now, it's like genuinely,
I have to like, fucking, like precise,
like precisely time
when I drink water now,
otherwise I'm gonna wake
up, at like 6 A.M. to pee.
- I almost, that's the thing,
I almost never drink water
before I go to bed, or
never drink anything-
- Is this like an old age thing?
Is this an aging thing?
- What the fuck.
You're 24-
(Joey laughs)
What are you talking about?
- Am I showing early signs
of 40 year old life?
Like why is this happening?
- Am I right, fellow older gentlemen?
- I turned 24.
The clock ticked over,
and I was like, "Shit.
My body's falling apart.
My life is going to shit.
Losing my hair, I'm pissing everywhere.
My bladder hurts all the time".
You know, it's like, what's going on?
I can't catch a fucking break.
When did my body start doing this?
This never happened before.
I have this really vivid memory,
this is totally on tangent,
about peeing though.
Where, for some reason, when
I watched "Wild Wild West"
for the first time-
- (laughs) Okay.
- At 12 years old, for some reason,
I was so, so proud of myself (laughing)
as an eight year old kid,
that I'd managed to sit
through a whole movie without peeing.
(Garnt laughs)
- I mean yeah-
- I would be proud as well.
I still can't do that.
- When you're a kid,
would you just piss all the time?
- Yes, I mean-
- I still piss all the time.
- So is this like, a curve-
- Me and Connor
are like piss machine
2,000, we piss all the time.
- Piss machine...
Is this a thing that happens in life,
that you know, when you're
a kid you have to pee a lot,
and then you pee less, and
then when you get to like,
mid-20s, it goes back-
- No, I pee just as much now
as I did when I was eight.
- I think you were just
getting onto like, our level now,
of like, how much you pee.
- I'm not fond of this.
- Yeah, I mean, I drink a lot of water.
I mean just, look at that.
- God, look at this.
This is a full glass, believe it or not,
this is a full glass of water
that I just drank. (laughs)
- The amount-
- You could scarcely-
- Before I started
the sentence, it was full.
- The amount of like,
the amount of fucking,
on or off camera moments on "Trash Taste",
where I'm just like talking,
and then my glass is just empty.
And I have to like, I go through-
- Are you talking about your weird like,
side mouth drinking shit that you do?
- (laughing) I'm not talking about that.
- Can I hear an explanation about that?
Why do you do that?
- I have, I did not
even know I did that.
- I get it.
Sometimes, drinking water's boring.
You gotta spice it up a little.
(Joey laughs)
No, no, you've done
this, you've done this.
When you've just drank
water in a funny way,
because you're like, you're bored-
- Yeah, when I was like, 10.
- Nah, I still do that.
I still do that shit.
- And then I realized,
oh, I should probably
just drink it how everyone else drinks it-
- Thank you very much
for the refill, Meiling.
Yes, I did need to stay hydrated.
Yeah, I don't know-
- Do you know,
sometimes you slurp excessively?
You know, to like, aerate the water?
And all the flavors come out? (laughs)
- I actually don't do that,
what are you talking about?
- I'm kidding-
- Like a fine wine-
- I'm kidding.
- Swirl it around, like a fine wine-
- Do you ever drink water like a dog?
Just like-
(men laugh)
- Yeah I did, when I was 10.
- That moment when.
- Well yeah, because
actually, when you're kid,
you're like, "The dog's
doing it, clearly"-
- Yeah, I watched my cat do it.
And I was like, "Whoa, I wanna do that".
- Yeah, why doesn't the
stupid dog just drink it?
- Yeah. (laughs)
Just pick it up.
(Connor laughs)
- And then you try it, and you're like,
"This is wildly inefficient.
This really feels like
there could have been
a better way of the dog"-
- No wonder those motherfuckers
have been at this bowl
for like five minutes.
- Are you telling me over
thousands of years of evolution,
the dog couldn't slurp?
(Joey laughs)
A little bit, it couldn't just figure out-
- Just pucker his lips, mm.
- These dogs have like,
near fucking echolocation,
and you're telling me they
couldn't develop a slurp?
Like...
I could learn that shit with
a YouTube guide in 20 minutes.
Are you kidding me?
- How to slurp.
- Wikihow.
- Oh my God.
- I don't know-
- Don't be a dog.
- How did we get onto this?
I don't know, point is,
stay hydrated, weebs.
It's healthy for you.
Right? (laughs)
- I mean yeah, it is, it is.
- I mean yeah, I don't know.
I've always just drunk
a fuck ton of water,
ever since I was a kid.
Which is why I think, while like,
one of my biggest habits that I have
that's allowed me to stay thin,
is that I just don't
really like soda that much.
It's just, I'd rather drink...
Okay, here's the thing, I hate soda
when it's at full fizziness.
Right.
- What the fuck
are you talking about?
- Okay, okay, okay.
We're going off tangent, I only thought-
- Please, please, go on-
- Tangent, the episode.
- Yeah, this is tangent, the episode.
I only thought about
this because I saw like,
another hot takes Sydney tweet last night.
- Oh that one.
- Which was like,
I can't remember exactly, but it was like-
- "Flat soda is better than fizzy soda".
- I turned off my
computer after I saw that.
I was like, "You can't be serious".
- And I'm like just, "I
don't agree with that".
But, I half agree with that.
Because I cannot for the life of me
fully enjoy fully fizzy soda.
Like, for me, peak soda, right,
I cannot drink-
- Peak soda!
- This happens when
you sleep on the floor.
You just start fucking doing weird things-
- Welcome to another gone hot food take.
Okay, peak soda for me,
is soda with ice, right?
Because you have to like,
you pour it on the ice-
- It gets it down-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I do like a little bit watered down soda.
Because like, for me, Coke out of a can,
it's so fizzy, that you just can't,
I don't understand how-
(Joey laughs)
It is, it is!
- Is your throat
made out of paper?
Like-
- Oh, oh it hurts.
- Oh it hurts!
- It's just fucking
gassy as fuck, like soda, a drink,
is meant to be refreshing-
- You can't tell me,
you can't tell me after you down
a fully fizzy soda,
doesn't have to be Coke.
Just any soda, because I don't
drink Coke anymore either.
But after you just open
it, and you hear that,
(imitates a can of soda
opening) like sound,
you drink it down, and then you do that
massive fucking burp.
- The burp is very nice.
- Is like, the best fucking
feeling on the planet.
- Yeah, normally, I'm
always willing to understand
your point, Garnt, but honestly,
I don't even know where
this is coming from.
This is weird.
- This is coming from-
- Because I've never
drank soda, and been like,
"Damn, I wish this was
less carbonated". (laughs)
- I think all of them, because to me,
a drink is meant to be refreshing, right?
That's why we drink it-
- But the carbonation's-
- It's meant to be refreshing-
- The carbonation
is supposed to be refreshing!
- The carbonation is not refreshing.
- It's pretty refreshing.
- It's not refreshing.
- Well like, it's either
sugared-out flat ass soda
is definitely not refreshing.
- No, no, no, I don't like flat soda.
I do not like flat soda.
Flat soda is awful, right.
It's just, when it's like, on ice,
you get a bit of the fizz out,
and that's the perfect amount
of carbonation in a soda.
That's why, if I drink soda,
if I want it to be refreshing,
it needs a little bit of ice,
just to get a bit of that
carbonation out, perfect amount.
- Too long.
(Garnt laughs)
It's what it sounds like. (laughs)
Who taught you this?
- This man wants to hydrate
no matter what.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's just, I mean like-
- It's like,
soda doesn't have water in it.
- Yeah I mean like, a
fully carbonated soda,
I feel like I'm losing
hydration by drinking that.
I don't know why.
- All right, to be fair,
the only, I don't drink
soda anymore either.
I haven't really drank soda
in like, maybe a couple years.
I mean, every now and then,
if there's a drink bar
or whatever-
- You haven't drank soda
in a couple years?
- Sometimes, okay no.
I haven't, dead ass, I haven't
bought a bottle of Coke,
or Sprite-
- Oh, I haven't done that-
- In a couple years.
- You know, it's like,
when I order at McDonald's, I have to-
- No, I always get tea at McDonald's.
- I used to get milk, but
then I just felt like a child.
- Milk?
- Milk, at McDonald's?
- When the milk carton
would turn off, I would
get Uber Eats, you know.
And like you have to order-
- I didn't even know
you could get milk at McDonald's.
- You can get milk in it.
And the carton would turn up, and the guy,
you know, the Uber Eats guy-
- The milk man, right.
- He'd look at me like,
"Seriously, seriously?
All right, okay".
- Oh, here's your little milk. (giggles)
- Well, because, I don't
know if this is like
a tactical thing, to get
us to drink more Coke.
But the just start putting
water in the package deal,
and I was really offended by that.
Because it's literally from a tap.
- So why were you offended?
Just go to your tap.
- Well, just sometimes,
I wanna get the value of
a meal, like the deal.
But I-
- Sometimes I want
to support a multi-billion
dollar corporation!
- I wanna feel like I got
'em back a little bit.
You know, I wanna save
a little bit of money
on this rip-off, you know.
Because I really like
the McDonald's fries.
So I want the fries with the burger.
And you have to get a drink,
and I don't really know what I want.
I don't want milk either, it
just sat there on my fridge.
And I would like, I
stabbed it in the carton,
squeezed it into my tea.
Really depressingly.
- You can get milk at McDonald's?
- (laughs) Yes!
- Are you lagging, Garnt?
- I was just agreeing, and
then I was like, "Wait.
That doesn't compute in my mind".
- Yeah, well it's kids,
kids wanna drink milk.
- It's like the golden arches M for milk.
(men laugh)
- I have never seen milk at McDonald's-
- Milk. (laughs)
- Because like, I know you can get water-
- It's not on the fucking front of shop,
like "Look, check out
our milk", it's like-
- No, no, no-
- We have milk.
- I know you can get like, juice boxes.
I know you can get a bottle of water.
I've never seen anyone get milk before-
- It's because no one fucking-
- Yeah, no one
fucking orders it-
- The expiration date
on this thing must have
been 10 years past.
I'm pretty sure they fucking dusted it off
before they put it in my
fucking Uber Eats order.
- Just yogurt at that point.
(Garnt laughs)
Probably what they're
putting into the McFlurries.
- I had to fucking carve it out.
It was like butter when I got it.
It was like fuck it, it was so bad-
- It's why the fucking milkshake machines
are never working, right.
Because they just don't have enough milk.
- This motherfucker keeps buying our milk!
We need it for the milkshake machine.
- That's how I feel whenever I buy
my fucking tea from Starbucks.
I'm like, "I feel like I'm
doing something wrong".
- Aw, I didn't even
know you could do that.
- Yeah, of course you can. (laughs)
- Yeah, you can buy tea at Starbucks.
- Who buys tea at Starbucks?
- Well, some of them are okay, actually.
But I used to feel like,
now it's a bit more,
I feel like tea's become more mainstream.
And like-
- Where?
- It's a fashion statement now-
- I feel like 10 years ago,
coffee was like, the thing.
It was like, everyone just,
this is a weird thing, but in Starbucks,
it was all about coffee, coffee, coffee.
Now it's all like, everyone's chilled out.
You can order a fucking tea,
if you want a fucking tea.
Is that a weird statement?
I feel like, sometimes I make a point,
and I know this is gonna
be a really hard battle
to not look weird-
- It's not-
- I just went through
that five minutes ago-
- It's more like, I don't
go to Starbucks enough,
to be like, "Oh, there's a
new trend coming in here,
ladies and gentlemen, it's tea now".
- No, I just remembered that like,
I feel like I got mocked
when I ordered tea one time
at the Starbucks.
- What, by who?
- By my classmates. (laughing)
- Oh.
- When I was like, 15, I ordered a tea.
And they were like (scoffs).
- At Starbucks.
- Men drink coffee, Connor.
Yeah, yeah-
- Men drink coffee-
- I feel like, it's more, back then,
why would you go to Starbucks
for anything but a coffee?
- [Joey] A coffee, yeah.
- I feel like, that's
what it was back then.
And now everyone doesn't
really give a fuck,
and you can get what you want.
- I mean, I feel in England especially,
you get a tea, you can get
a tea fucking anywhere.
It's fucking England.
Everyone there drinks tea-
- I think that's what it is.
It's more like, you
could get a tea anywhere.
So why did you get it at Starbucks?
- Yeah, back, you know,
back when I worked at the BBC Euro-
- There it is-
- Roll credits.
- Roll credits, mark
it off your bingo card-
- Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-
- Bingo!
- No, but yeah, back when
I worked in the office,
you know, every so
often, with the newbies,
or the interns, or the graduates,
they were always on tea duty.
And I was like that one
person in my entire team
of like, 20, I'm just like, "Actually,
can I get a coffee please?"
Like, literally everyone
around me drank tea!
That's what everyone drinks in England.
- And all the interns scoffed at that.
Like (scoffs).
- Coffee?
- Coffee, what's that?
- We're in England.
- The UK's weird,
because like, most British
people don't even drink
any other type than English Breakfast tea.
Like, I think most people from the UK,
if you ask them, "I want a cup of tea",
they would not ever even
consider anything else,
other than-
- Like they don't specify
the type of tea, right-
- Well that's the thing
in the UK, if you ask for a cup of tea,
you're getting English Breakfast-
- Just a, I didn't even know
it was called English Breakfast, right.
Yeah, I just knew it was a tea-
- Yeah, that's why we have brands, right.
In the UK, when you say "I want a tea",
you get the same type of tea.
- Right, unless you specify, right?
- If you sit there in someone's house,
and you're like, "Oh, I want a tea".
And they're like, "Oh, do you have like,
green tea, or some chai",
they'd be like, "What the fuck?"
- No, no, that's-
- This guy.
- Really?
- It's weird-
- So if I came into your house in the UK-
- Maybe-
- No, no,
because if you want a
different kind of tea,
you have to specify.
- Yeah, right?
- But even then, most houses,
I don't think most houses
have other types of tea.
- So if I went
into a house and just said,
"Can I have some chamomile tea?"
They'd be like-
- They'd probably be like,
"Whoa"-
- Whoa, whoa.
Chamomile tea, what the fuck is that?
- [Joey] What the fuck is that?
- We just have tea.
- I feel like
those types of teas are
almost like luxury teas
in the UK-
- Oh.
- Yeah, because they always
come in like, fancy packaging.
Because like, the British type is like,
it comes in like, 500 pack,
because that'll last you
one month in the UK.
(laughs) Like, if you've
got a family as well...
Everyone in your family's drinking tea.
So this is like, when
Americans ask me that,
what kind of tea are you drinking, Connor?
It's like, well, I have a tea,
and then I have an afternoon tea.
You know, where you try everything.
You try the Earl Greys,
you try the other types.
But if I'm drinking tea,
I have English Breakfast.
- In the morning.
- No, all day-
- All day, all day.
- But it's called English Breakfast.
- Yeah, but it's, people just drink it
like they drink coffee, it's like a-
- Yeah, but don't they
call it morning coffee?
- No, no, it's like
Earl Grey, or whatever.
It's like the type of-
- It's just part
of British culture.
You just need to chill out with a cuppa-
- But I realized how strange
it was, when going to America.
It's like, that's not at all how it is.
- No.
- It's like-
- If you say-
- Americans
don't drink tea anyway.
- Well, I think they,
(sighs) they kind of do.
- I think they do.
But again, if you order-
- But other countries-
- If you order tea-
- Do you know how I know
Americans don't drink tea?
- Why?
- Because, have you seen
their fucking kettles?
- That's true, that's true.
- Like, no culture that drinks tea
is built around the fucking kettles
that the Americans use.
- What kind of kettles do Americans use?
- Oh, they're just these terrible things.
They're these awful
things that can hold like,
maybe 500 mills, not even
enough cups for two people.
In the UK-
- And you've gotta
put it on the stove, right.
- Oh, those ones.
- You put it on the stove, and as a Brit,
I'm like, "Fucking, the
heat efficiency of this
is giving me clinical depression".
(Joey laughs)
"What the fuck is this?"
I'm just like-
- Yeah, you know,
when I go to someone's house in the UK,
and they start doing that shit,
I'm like, "What are you
doing, what are you doing?"
Come on.
- No, no, no.
I'll tell you the one thing that gave me
a fucking brain aneurism,
as someone who doesn't even
drink tea, right.
So-
- You don't drink tea?
You don't drink tea at all?
- I'm mostly a coffee drinker.
I'm mostly a coffee drinker.
- Let me tell you about tea.
This thing I don't drink-
- No, no, but anyway-
- Tell me about the thing you don't drink-
- I don't drink English
Breakfast tea, a lot of times.
But I drink green tea-
- He's a fancy motherfucker,
right here-
- Wow, Garnt-
- I mean, I've-
- Think you're better
than us, you think you're
better than the working man?
(Joey laughs)
- I would say that-
- Because he worked
at the BBC.
(men laughs)
- I'd say the amount of
tea selection in Asia,
just fucking eclipses
whatever we have in England.
- We have that tea.
- You just don't order it.
- You have to go to the
store manager and be like,
"Can you unlock the safe?"
(Joey laughs)
Can you show us
the other variations of tea? (chuckles)
- The tea you dug up.
- You have to like, move all
the other teas in the aisle
to the back, so you can grab these things.
- Yeah, it's like, you
go to a fucking konbini,
it's like opening Pandora's boxes of tea.
You've got an entire fucking selection.
And in England, like what have you got?
Like Lipton iced tea?
That's pretty, I don't even count that
as a fucking tea.
- Well to be fair,
in the konbini, in Japan, it is like,
"Here's the 59th version of green tea".
And it's like, you literally can't make,
I don't even actually think
it's chemically possible
for there to be 59
variations of green tea.
(men laugh)
How much molecular division are we doing
to these bonds here?
- It's just like
leaves they picked from
like the 59th field.
- It's absurd, and half of
them taste the fucking same,
and it doesn't matter-
- I like this tea,
which is like, I don't even
know what the fuck this is.
- Yeah, you could live
in Japan for five years,
and try a new tea different
day, it's fucking easy.
- Well I've tried most of them-
- Yeah, you've tried
every Japanese tea, right?
- I can confirm that half of them taste
exactly the fucking same, yeah.
There was also like, in Japan
they had low fat green teas,
or healthy green teas.
And I'm like, "Green tea is
healthy, what do you mean?"
(Joey giggles)
What are the-
- Does green tea
have calories?
- No, it doesn't-
- No, no it doesn't.
- But there's like,
healthier versions-
- (laughs) Low calorie
green tea, what the fuck is that?
- There was like-
- Negative calorie green tea-
- It was like, good health green tea.
And I'm like, "Green tea
is, I actually think,
one of the healthiest
teas of all the teas".
- Yeah, it is.
- So what do you mean?
Like, what have they
done to the other teas?
- Guys, I can do one better.
I've got an idea, zero calorie water-
- Shut the fuck up.
(Garnt laughs)
- By drinking it, you lose calories.
- But I just, going
back to the whole thing,
I just get very amazed, that like,
because Americans are always asking
people from other countries
like, "What tea do you drink?"
They're like, "I drink
Earl Grey, I drink this",
it's like, no, no, no, in the
UK, it's not like that at all.
Like, that's not how it works.
- Are you sure that's not
like, just your household?
- No, no, no, it's all of the UK.
You go anywhere, you want
a cup of tea, you get it.
Like, no matter where you go-
- Yeah, it's only in the UK
where if you say tea, it
means one type of tea.
And I just always thought, that's tea.
That's just tea.
Every other tea it's just
like the branded tea, right.
- I guess it's the same in Japan as well.
If you go to someone's household,
and you ask for ocha, which is tea,
you usually get green
tea unless you specify.
- That's like the default skin in Japan.
- It's also weird, like the
lengths the British will go to,
to bring tea with them, or
have a cup of tea available.
I remember like, you know,
whenever you go camping, or
on an expedition or whatever,
I remember there was a
guy, from when we did like,
Duke of Edinburgh, who,
he drove a car around to keep up with us.
But in this thing, there was this whole,
massive hot water tank, just for tea.
So that we could all have tea.
And I didn't think that was weird-
- On Duke of Edinburgh?
- Yeah, yeah, so we could
all have a cup of tea
when we were done at the end of the day.
Because that's, the British people,
that's how you signify the work is down.
- Yeah, work is done-
- Also, whenever we
went paintballing in the
UK, or anything like that,
during the break, you get tea.
(Joey laughs)
It'd be like, you'd be
like fucking warfare,
and they'd be like, "Stop, chaps.
Time for the tea break".
- Tea break.
- And you'd go for a tea break.
(laughs) And now that I
think about this out loud-
- That's so weird.
- But I'm like,
yeah, we go to like, no matter
what you're doing in the UK,
someone is gonna try and
put a cup of tea available.
The stereotype is totally true.
- It is totally true.
Like, the best analogy I can think of
is that to Britons, to Brits, a cup of tea
is like the equivalent to
a cigarette break, right?
It's just an excuse to put on the kettle,
drink a bunch of tea and just
chill out for five minutes.
- Yeah, we have those in Australia.
We don't have tea breaks, we have smokos.
- (laughs) Smokos.
- Yeah, smokos-
- Two shots of vodka, and
send you back to work.
- Are we allowed a smoko?
All right, let's go.
- Getting back to why
I know Americans don't drink tea, right-
- Kettles are shit.
- Yeah, one,
kettles are shit, two, like okay.
So, I remember I was staying with Sydney,
and she had a little bit of a,
or someone had a sore throat, right.
So we just needed some warm water.
Right, and so, how would
you make warm water?
- Boil it in a kettle-
- Boil it in a kettle,
and then put, you know,
put the hot water in,
and then just fill it with cold water.
So, Sydney takes the mug,
and fills it up with water-
- I know what you're gonna say.
- Puts it in the microwave-
- Oh no.
(Garnt laughs)
- I knew it was coming.
- Puts it in the microwave,
and puts on a counter.
And I'm just like, "What
are you doing, Sydney?"
I feel like I'm getting a brain aneurism,
just watching this right now-
- That's horrible.
That's horrible.
- And I was just like,
"There's no way this is normal".
There's no way this is fucking normal.
And so, she says, "No,
it's a normal thing here".
And I'm just like, "Bet".
And I tweet, I'm just like, "Americans,
is this a normal thing to do?"
And the amount of like, "What's wrong?
How do you heat up your water?"
Like, I'm just like,
"How is this?"
How have we gone through
thousands of years
of civilization, to heat
up water in a microwave?
- I'm gonna do my
obligatory insult Americans
this podcast.
- Mark that
off the bingo-
- Mark off the bingo.
(men laugh)
- Americans literally think the microwave
is the tool from God.
- Yeah.
- It can just-
- Do everything, yeah.
- Do everything, fuck. (laughs)
"Kitchen Nightmares" has taught me that.
I'm kidding, it's totally
reality obviously.
I don't know, recently I
abandoned my kettle in Japan.
I got rid of it.
- Really?
- Because it was, you know,
British kettles are intense.
Like-
- (snorts) How so?
- You know, when we
boil kettles in the UK,
it's done in what, like one minute?
- Yeah.
- Two minutes max.
That's a shit kettle, if
it's any longer than that.
You won't get, even the
shittiest of kettles don't take,
like, the worst kettles
you find are in hotels.
And like, you put the water on,
you come back 40 minutes
later, shit's still boiling,
making the world's loudest sound somehow.
(men imitating bubbling water)
It's like, how is this the shittiest.
This is a chain, surely
you could have got a deal
from the manufacture to
get a not shit kettle-
- Half the water's evaporated by the time-
- Literally, it's gone
by the time you fucking,
what, you've got fucking
200 milliliters of water?
It's like, not even fills up the cup.
It's absolutely abysmal.
It's like wasted half the fucking hotel's
electricity as well,
it's fucking dreadful.
But, in Japan as well,
they have the same thing,
and in America it's the same.
The kettles take so God damn long to boil.
And they're so shit, I got so tired of it,
because I'm streaming, between games.
I don't wanna be waiting
for like, five minutes.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm streaming.
I can't sit there and wait.
So I found, Japan has
these things that I've,
again, I've never seen these before.
But they're just like,
they have them in konbinis,
where it's a boiling water jug.
- Oh, I know the ones-
- Yeah, well you can fill the ramen up.
- Oh, yes, yes, yes-
- The ones where you like,
can pour it, right?
- It's like a two liter jug,
or whatever, you fill it up with water,
and then it boils it,
or it doesn't boil it.
You can choose the temperature.
- Yeah, yeah, and it's just always hot.
- It's always hot, and I
think it uses less electricity
than constantly reboiling a kettle.
- Yeah.
- And I felt so big brain, because now-
- You just have hot water ready-
- Literally, I can just go to the thing,
put the bag in, boom, hot water.
I'm like, "Shit"-
- Because that's
what every Asian uses for cup ramen.
That's the cup ramen
machine, and tea machine.
- And I'm like, "Shit,
maybe kettles are obsolete".
(men laugh)
Maybe this is the way.
- Goodbye, kettles.
- I was kind of like,
"Shit, a kettle has been
the first appliance I buy-
- I'd never thought about it like that.
Because I've seen that
all the time in Asia.
Because that's just readily available,
whenever I come to Thailand, holy shit.
Yeah, that's true, that's true.
That is more efficient than-
- It's so much more efficient.
And you literally have it ready.
- But anything's better than
a fucking microwave, okay.
Please don't do that, stop it, get help!
- So, you know, it's called
Sixth Form in the UK,
I forgot what it's called in America.
There was a guy, and we like
a microwave and a kettle
in our dorm room, or chill
room, it was for like,
your tea is there.
And this guy was like,
"You want a cup of tea?"
Yeah, I'll have a cup of tea.
You won't believe this, man.
He puts water in the
cup, puts the tea bag in,
and then puts it in the microwave.
- (laughing) Oh my, I'm about to fucking,
I'm about to fucking leave right now.
- The entire tea bag?
(Garnt laughing)
- Like, he pours the water, cold,
into the cup with the tea bag, cold-
- Oh my God.
- Lets it like,
stew, and then puts it in the microwave,
and heats it up.
And I've never seen anyone else do this.
And I'm like, "Who taught you this?"
Like, someone had to teach you this.
Because no one else would ever do this.
And I'm like, "I bet his
fucking parents are freaks.
What else do they do?
Do they like, fucking eat their toenails?
Like, what else is going
on in this household".
Like, you can't trust them
when they do that shit.
- It's like the family was like,
"Let's make some tea", and it's cold-
- And then I-
- And then one day
they discovered, people drink tea hot.
- And then I realized, I'm like,
"Shit, this is the most
British thing ever".
Because he got shit for it,
for like a year and a half.
- I think you could be an American
and get shit-
- He literally got bullied
for a year and a half
for making tea wrong.
Isn't that the most British
thing you've ever heard?
- Well deserved, if you ask me-
- And honestly, he had it coming.
Jesus Christ.
- Honestly,
like you know that fucking meme,
where if aliens ever invaded humanity,
and they have to blend in with the crowd?
That's the kind of shit
we would look out for,
to be like, "Oh, you're a
fucking imposter, aren't ya"-
- I too make tea, human.
(Garnt laughs)
(men laughing)
It's like the most alien move ever.
Cup of tea.
- Honestly, there's nothing more British
than being like, very
possessive over our tea,
and being very protective over our tea.
- Did I tell you about
the shittiest cup of tea
my brother ever made me?
- Okay.
- Go on.
- He made two of them,
he made two of them.
- Go on.
- You know, and this is the problem,
when you kind of do it half right,
and then fuck up one step,
is that it looks good,
it smells good, it looks as it should.
So the first time he did it for me,
I asked him to make me a cup of tea,
and he reluctantly said yes.
Can't remember how I convinced him.
Because he would never
do anything like that.
He's a brother, he never
does anything nice for me.
- Must have been in a good mood.
- Yeah, I must have done something right.
So he makes me a cup of
tea, and I'm drinking it.
And I'm like, "Mm", and I get to the end,
and like, (spitting loudly).
He fucking ripped the bag open.
(men cracking up)
He thought, because he'd never
made a cup of tea before.
So assumed the bag was like-
- What's all this shit
in this bag? (laughs)
Rip.
- Because, I think,
I think what happened was,
is that he'd had instant coffee before.
- Right, right-
- And he thought,
he thought it looked like instant coffee.
So he thought that you rip the bag open,
pour in the perfectly
portioned instant tea.
And then, (laughs) he stirred it.
And I get to the end of
this, and I'm fucking choking
on these shitty tea leaves!
And then I scolded him, I
never let him forget it.
And then again, like a year or two later,
he makes me another cup of tea, right.
- How can you fuck up a
cup of tea more than once?
- Yeah, right, this is it.
So this was actually at
the paintballing place.
Because I remember this.
- Doing your tea break-
- Literally fucking freezing,
right, we're covered in mud.
I'm just like, "Oh, I just
want a good cup of tea".
I was like, because my little brother,
some of his friends are my friends.
And I was like, "You're on the tea duty".
So he goes to make a cup
of tea for me and like,
six other people.
And I swear, it must have been like,
you know, it was like some kind of
cult poisoning-esque thing.
Because, we'd all drink our tea,
and when we get to the bottom,
he fucking left the bag in.
(Garnt laughs)
He put the milk in, right?
So you can't see the bag-
- You can't see the bag.
- And then, when you get to it,
and it fucking tea fucking
bag hit me in the face!
- You literally got tea bagged.
(men laugh)
- I got fucking, the tea bag
hit me in the god damn face!
And like, "What the fuck!"
- Ah!
- I'm like, "You're British,
you're 15 years of age,
you have no excuse, this
should never have happened".
Literally, there should have
been things to stop this.
Isn't this what school is for?
- Of all the different ways
you could have fucked up tea,
he did all of them.
- Pretty he could be
exiled from England for doing that.
- Right!
(men laughing)
- I'm pretty sure a lot of British people
would kick you out of their house
if you made their tea like that.
- Probably why Brexit happened, right.
(Joey laughs)
They're like, "Fucking
Europeans can't make a good
cup of tea", out.
- Gone.
- This episode is sponsored by Harry's.
- Boys, you look like you need a shave.
Thank God Harry's is
sponsoring us, am I right?
- [Garnt] With Harry's,
you don't need to choose
between having a great
shave and a fair price.
- Damn right.
- Neither should any guy
in their life, especially Connor.
And with Father's day
right around the corner,
there's never been a
better time to try or share
the Harry's experience.
- Thank you dad.
Let me tell you about the time
when I used Harry's (laughs).
- It's okay, son.
- I know we're no
strangers to memeing here,
but this is legitimately a good razor,
and I use it, and I keep asking them
to send me more, personally,
because it's actually that good.
I highly recommend it,
and it lasts a while.
It's really fucking good.
Just, no bull shit, no cap.
- No cap.
- Thank you very much, son.
Other son, tell me about Harry's.
- [Joey] You can redeem a trial set
for just $3, or get $5 off any shave set
when you go to harrys.com/trashtaste.
- You know what, gentlemen?
Harry's delivers a
close, comfortable shave
a at fair price.
- Can't complain.
- [Garnt] Still as low as $2 per refill.
- Oh, damn.
Harry's border factory in German
has been making precision
engineered blades
for over 100 years, that's a long time.
And, did you know they
have a 100% guarantee?
Harry stands behind the quality
of their blades so much,
they're offering a 100%
money back guarantee
on harrys.com.
- New Harry's customers
can get a starter set for just $3.
Plus, Harry's is doing
a limited time offer
for all customers, starting
now through Fathers Day,
you can take $5 off any shave sets
at harrys.com/trashtaste.
- What, damn.
But wait, there's more.
There's never truly been a better time
to try Harry's, go to
harrys.com/trashtaste
to start your own Harry's journey,
or to save a few bucks on a special gift
for a special dad in your life.
- Sons, I'd say that's
a pretty special offer.
- Thank you father, back to the episode.
- I am curious though, Joey.
So, what's the one sign you look for,
to know that you're
talking to a true Aussie?
Because for us Brits, it
all revolves around tea.
What's Australia patriotic about?
- (laughs) That's a
good question, because-
- How many cockroaches have you eaten?
(Garnt laughs)
- How many, do you spray?
Not a true Aussie. (laughs)
I don't know, I'm not very patriotic.
So-
- No, no, no.
Because I was like,
England's not very patriotic.
But when it comes to tea,
yeah, we're fucking
patriotic as fuck over our-
- Are we not patriotic?
I feel like, I don't
know, I've met a lot of-
- I mean, not to say-
- Way too patriotic people.
- Yeah I mean, not to say like,
I don't love my country or whatever,
but like, I don't know, I just,
I guess maybe (sighs), God.
It's hard with Australia, because I feel
it's such a melting pot
of different cultures,
that all of my friends in high school
had something specific about their family
that made it very distinctively Aussie.
But I'd say like, I don't know,
maybe the type of beer you drink.
(Garnt laughs)
- The type of what?
- I drink real,
Australian beer.
- Oh, the type of beer.
- Fosters.
- Yeah, if you say
Fosters, then you are getting
exiled from Australia.
I don't know, and then I guess like,
what you order at a pub.
I don't know-
- Yeah, basically.
- We don't really have-
- This sounds like
the "40 Year Old Virgin" scene,
where he's describing how
it feels to feel a boob.
Where it's just like,
not even remotely real.
It's like, Joey'd be like,
"It's the type of beer
they order"-
- I don't know.
I'm just throwing guesses out there-
- Feels like a bag of sand!
- Right.
- Bag of sand, yeah.
- I love that fucking scene.
- Fucking brilliant scene.
- If you get that reference,
that'll make a lot of sense.
If you don't, it'll make no fucking sense.
- Go watch the "40 Year Old Virgin".
- If you haven't, watch
that film, it's great.
- I don't know, like-
- You're like,
I feel like you're-
- With Aussies,
it's just, you start talking to them,
and then you kind of get a sense of it.
Right, like you just know,
you know how much of
an Aussie an Aussie is
with the way that they
interact in conversation,
and the way that you get
immediately close to them.
- Yeah, I feel that as well.
For me, whenever I meet an Aussie,
I have this thing where
it's like, the CPM.
Like you know-
(Joey laughs)
Music has beats per minute?
So, when you talk to an Aussie,
they have cunts per minute-
(Joey laughs)
Right.
Where (laughs)-
- I'm so confused.
- I was like, cost per million?
What?
- No, like the amount of
times they use the C-word
in a single sentence.
You can fucking count that shit,
(laughs) and put it as
a CPM, I swear to God.
- That is true, that is true.
- I don't know what your
typing words per minute is.
I wanna know what your CPM is.
- Yeah, what's your CPM?
(men laugh)
No, that is true.
We call our mates C-word,
and we call C-words mates.
(Garnt laughs)
That's how it works in Australia.
- [Garnt] That's exactly how it works!
- If you see a friend
from across the street,
and you want to call out to them,
you'd be like, "Oy, cunt".
But if you bump into someone at a pub,
you'd be like, "Oy, mate?"
(Garnt laughs)
I feel like, if you hear
an Aussie doing that,
that's a true Aussie.
If they're not afraid to say the C-word.
- Going back to like, the
fucking bugs and spiders,
as someone who did grow up in Australia,
some of the shit you've seen,
do they scare you at all?
Or are you just unfazed by them now?
- I'm only scared if
I know it's poisonous.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
So like, there was this insect,
so on "Journey Across
Japan", talked about it
a couple of episodes ago,
but we went into this
area, where there was a lot
of creepy crawlies, and Chris was not okay
with any of the creepy crawlies.
The trooper he is, he's not
okay with any creepy crawlies.
And there was this one
particular insect that I saw,
which, I mean you'll see
it hopefully in the episode
when it comes out, but the
only way I can describe it
is it looks like a centipede
and a cockroach had a baby.
That's what it looks like.
It moves around like a cockroach,
but it's kind of got
the body of a centipede.
It is like, true nightmare fuel.
- What the fuck? (laughs)
- I don't even know,
Moona, I don't even know
if you wanna like, put
the image on the screen
or whatever, but like, yeah it's horrible.
So like, I saw that in this little area.
Chris obviously freaked the fuck out.
And I was freaking out,
because I didn't know,
because I think there's
a breed of centipede
in Japan that's poisonous.
So I-
- Aren't all centipedes
poisonous?
- Not all of them.
- Okay.
- No, some of them
taste good.
(men laugh)
- That's what my dad said.
- I'm pretty sure they're edible.
- Are they?
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm sure they are-
- Fantastic source of protein.
- I'm pretty sure
cockroaches are edible too,
but I don't wanna eat them.
I'll give it to my dad. (laughs)
- That's why I love the food
on "Kitchen Nightmares",
because it always comes free with them.
- Yeah, exactly.
But like, I didn't know
if that was the breed
of poisonous centipede.
But that's what was freaking me out.
Was like, if this thing is
poisonous, then I'm scared.
- Joey's like, "Get out
the fucking Pokedexes"-
- No, I legitimately said-
- Does this look like
a poison type?
- I literally,
on the spot, I looked it up.
I was like, "Poisonous centipede, Japan".
And I looked it up, and I referenced it.
And I was like, "Okay, it's not it".
- So the filtered version,
with the nice one.
You're looking at it like, "Fuck".
- Expectations versus reality.
- It's got like, a mad
filter on it here dude.
Fuck it's-
- Yeah, I don't know.
It's like, because you know,
obviously because there's
lots of creepy crawlies
and shit in Australia.
But like, the reason why
I'm scared of a lot of them
is because a lot of them can kill me.
- Yeah, I mean-
- And I'm not okay with that.
- Listen, I don't like bugs at all.
I'm frankly quite terrified of them.
But, I'll deal with them still.
I think that's, you know-
- That's admirable.
- That's manly.
- Yeah, that's admirable.
- Admitting that you're a little bitch,
and then dealing with it
anyway, that's real men.
- Like, if I know it's not
poisonous, I'll fucking touch it.
- But like, at what point
do you see an insect
or creepy crawly-
- I don't get scared
by any singular insect.
It's like, the thing
that terrifies me most-
- Collections of insects?
- Is like, swarms.
- Well yeah.
- Well, of course.
- But like-
- No one's gonna be like,
"Hell yeah".
- But okay, okay-
- Like, swarms of anything
terrifies the fuck out of me.
Like, there was a video, and it was like,
"South Australian farm gets
overrun by a horde of mice".
- Of mice?
- I shit you not, dude.
It looked like the floor was moving.
There were so many mice
running, it was terrifying.
And if I'm seeing that,
that's my farm, I'm like,
"Well, I'm out of a job,
have it, it's yours".
- Guess I'll die.
- It's your farm.
What the fuck am I gonna do?
- I feel like there are
so many stories I hear
from just talking to Australians,
that I'm just like, "How much did God
just hate Australia, and yet people still
have found a way to live there?"
- Okay, to be fair, my
place, my parents' place,
is like, our backyard is
right next to a national park.
So our house is basically just
a house for creepy crawlies.
It was like the first destination.
Like, we got snakes and
spiders all the fucking time.
But after a while, we're just like,
I mean, we do live right
in the fucking bush,
so whatever-
- I always wondered,
is there, was there an old Medieval method
of determining what's poisonous or not?
Or would they just give it to some poor-
- Trial by fire, isn't it?
- Was it really just-
- I've always thought
about this, like-
- They must have had
just one rich guy who was
like, "Well, random bunch
of the people who"-
- Yeah, how do you think
people discovered what
mushrooms were poisonous?
- Isn't that tragic though?
You're just like, "Oh hi, what's your job?
Well I'm a poison tester.
I'm three for three at the moment".
(Joey laughs)
- Do you know-
- Hoping tomorrow
will go well.
- But do you know what
blows my mind, how the fuck
did like, people in Japan
figure out which part of the
puffer fish wasn't poisonous?
Like-
- Also why-
- How many people had to die
to know the exact methods-
- But why also, did someone
die, they were like,
"We're gonna try it again". (laughs)
(men laugh)
- One more time.
- Guys, guys, guys.
We're 100 to zero on the
puffer fish right now,
but maybe, maybe this one time.
- There has to be somewhere
on this thing that's edible,
right?
- I just feel like,
after you find out something is poisonous,
I think it's okay to give
up, and not eat it, you know?
That's what I thought.
Is it-
- It's like,
"We gotta make sure, the
last guy might have had like,
side effects that he had beforehand"-
- Have you had their puffer fish?
- Yeah, couple times.
- I've heard it's very underwhelming.
- It's not great.
- Listen, if I'm gonna die,
I want it to be nut worthy, right?
Like, I want the risk
to be worth the reward.
- Yeah, of course.
- And it just looks like
really shitty sushi.
Not sushi, what's-
- What does it even
taste like?
- Nothing.
- (laughs) That's what I've heard.
- It actually tastes like nothing-
- That's what I've heard, like-
- It's just grown men wanting to die.
- Yeah.
- No, it's literally
just a status symbol.
It's to just say that
you've had a puffer fish.
- Because I've seen the videos,
and I'm just like, "This just looks like
you're eating fucking
cardboard", you know.
It doesn't look like
you're eating anything-
- Actually, you do know
what it tastes like?
The soy sauce that you dip it in.
That's what it tastes like.
- I love unagi. Unagi is one
of my favorite Japanese dishes.
And I found out on Saturday,
if you cook it incorrectly,
it's fucking poisonous.
- Yeah.
- No one told me that.
- Is it?
- That's why it's so expensive.
- It's poisonous as fuck. It can kill you.
- You know, I'll fucking risk it.
That's one thing I will risk!
Because it fucking slaps.
- And then,
I was like, "The element of
danger adds to the taste now".
Frankly, but if it's
not very good tasting-
- I feel like that's why a lot of people
eat puffer fish as well.
It's like, the element of
danger adds to the taste.
Whatever taste-
- Why does everyone
just wanna die?
- (laughs) Do you reckon
there's a guy out there
who's just like, "God, kill me.
I hope it's this time around".
- I'm pretty sure that's whoever like,
you know, I get it, right.
Because you know when you
see poisonous berries?
- Yeah.
- I still really
wanna try them, because
they look so delicious.
- Do you?
- Yeah, because in the UK
there's so many poisonous berries.
- Is there?
- That's how nature
fucks with you, dude.
It's the ones that look the most delicious
that'll kill you.
- Yeah, yeah.
Because those bright little red things.
You know, you see them everywhere-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah! (laughs)
- Oh, okay.
- That look so fucking
delicious when you're a kid.
- They look like mini tomatoes, right?
- I just wanna have a,
mm, get a bunch of those
and see what happens, you know?
- (laughs) Just see what happens.
- See what happens.
- That's probably how,
that's probably how people found out
they were poisonous, right?
- Well I get it.
Okay, let's say, you know,
you haven't got much food.
You know, you're struggling, all right.
You have a wander through the forest,
and you see a bunch of, you see a bush.
Enough food for the family.
(Garnt laughs)
- Enough food
to kill the family!
- Nobody told you
that they're poisonous, you know.
Like also, who got poisoned
by mushrooms, like,
"No, no, no, no, it must just
be this type of mushroom".
And goes out, and tries another one.
That's like, a very bold thing.
Like who's doing this?
- Well, someone had to, right?
- Someone did it back in the day-
- I'm convinced it must have been people
with too much money being
like, "I will literally
pay you $1,000"-
- Probably.
- Like, when's the "Mr.
Beast" video coming out?
Where he's like, "I pay people
$100,000 to try mushrooms,
to find out which one's poisonous.
How much shiitake mushroom will kill you?"
- Eat mushrooms, last one to
survive wins a million dollars.
- Oh no, if you want people to do it,
just make it a fucking
TikTok challenge, yeah?
- It's like, "So I found this
mushroom in my cupboard".
(Connor laughs)
- TikTok mushroom challenge, let's go-
- The deathcap challenge.
(men laugh)
Today I'm eating a deathcap.
Hope I survive.
- Oh my God.
- You know,
I think I would rather try my luck
eating a poisonous mushroom,
and just try my chance at surviving,
as opposed to putting my hand
on my iPhone for four days.
You know, for that keep
your hand on the iPhone?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, that one, that one.
- I think I would rather
poison myself than do that
for four days, that
sounds fucking horrible.
- Yeah, I know.
- I'm sure the pain
would be over with in two days.
If you just get to go to the
hospital, get it all sorted.
- Yeah, get slight arthritis,
and you'll be all right.
- I mean, if it's not a bad one.
You know, I'm sure there's
mushrooms out there
that just make you like, very much vomit.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, probably.
- I'm pretty sure
that's what-
- Which one
would you rather, Garnt?
Would you rather vomit
profusely for like, four hours?
Or would you rather put
your hand on an iPhone
for four hours and you can't sleep.
- I mean, you mean for four days?
- Four days, four days,
yeah not four hours.
That's very easy.
(men laugh)
- Oh no!
- Oh no.
- Four hours.
- Listen, have you ever tried
to stay up past one day?
- Dude like, how long is the
longest you've stayed up?
- Like, a day and a half.
- Me, for me,
it's like 36 hours.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 36 hours for me-
- And that's where
it starts to get like, fucking weird.
Like, your brain starts to
want to turn off desperately.
So like, and I feel like by the third day,
what on earth is going through your head?
But I couldn't do that.
And that's why I would just
rather eat the fucking mushroom
that might poison me.
Meiling, can you Google that?
Is there any mushrooms
that'll just make me
throw up a little bit?
- Like a little?
- Like not kill me, but like-
(Garnt laughs)
(laughs) Is this an option?
I just wanna make sure.
- Is this an option?
Is this DLC?
- I'll only start playing
with fair rules here.
- In this line,
I mean I wouldn't want
to do either, personally.
But personally, both sounds like hell.
- Listen, someone's come up with it,
and they'll be like, "Now
it's the mushroom cleanse".
You know-
- The mushroom cleanse!
- This mushroom will detox your body.
Yeah, because it's making
you fucking lose it all!
(Garnt laughs)
That's what they're doing, man.
- Oh my god.
- Muscarine.
- What does it make you do?
- [Meilin] For I guess,
after 15, 30 minutes,
you'll start getting diarrhea
and decreased blood pressure.
- Oh wow-
- That sounds pretty bad.
- That sounds-
- [Meilin] Severe vomiting, but
you recover within 24 hours.
- Okay, that's good then.
- Brilliant.
What was it called again?
- [Meilin] Muscaria?
- Muscary challenge.
(men laugh)
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- We've got 50 reasons we
are joking, this is a joke,
this I not real.
- For legal reasons,
this is a joke.
- We are joking around.
Please don't do that.
- That's only 10% less deadly
than the cinnamon challenge,
so really, it's okay.
Makes you wonder how
that was ever allowed-
- God, remember the
fucking cinnamon challenge?
Did you guys ever do that?
- No.
I've never done any, the
only challenge I've done
is like, the ice bucket challenge.
- Yeah, I did the ice bucket challenge.
- That's like-
- That was for a good cause.
- Yeah, that was for a good cause.
- Also, it's pretty tame-
- Easy.
- Yeah, it's like, breathe
oxygen for 20 minute challenge.
It's like, "Well I guess I'll"...
- Yeah, you get mild
discomfort for like, a second.
That was the ice bucket challenge, right?
- I got tagged on it,
I never did it though,
because I was feeling quite lazy.
And I didn't wanna get a bucket.
I didn't wanna get a, where
do you get a bucket big enough
when you're like, 15?
- I don't know-
- Borrow from your dad.
- From, did your house not have one?
- Probably somewhere, I
just didn't wanna find it.
- Just like a mop and bucket, right?
Every house has a-
- Or just get like a-
- Like a fucking mop bucket over my head.
- Or just get a big pot.
- Yeah.
- That's what some of my friends did.
- Well I mean, perhaps when I was 15,
maybe I should have been...
You know, I wasn't too
fond on doing it anyway
when I was a kid, so-
(Garnt laughs)
I was like, "Oh, I don't
have a bucket, oh fuck"-
- I hate charity, obviously.
- Well no, that's the thing though!
Shit like this, it's always like,
what is me, a 15 year
old kid on my Facebook
with 200 friends, what is this gonna help?
- Oh yeah, this was pre YouTube wasn't it.
- This was pre YouTube.
- No, no, no.
No it wasn't.
- For Connor.
- Oh, for you, yeah.
- This was like,
when I was high school, when
this was just coming out.
And I just thought, really silly Connor.
What are you gonna contribute here, huh?
Little bit of an ego boost for that,
in taking part in something, huh?
- Yeah, just do it with your mates.
- What is it Connor?
Come on, what are you fucking helping?
You're not doing this for charity, Connor.
You're doing this because
your friend tagged you.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Can't even get
the clout from it.
- What's the point?
What's the point?
- Why donate to charity, when
you can't get clout for it?
- Well no, when I was 15,
15 year olds that donate to charity
are like the biggest dick 15 year olds.
They're like, "I've got
like, 10 bucks, have it.
Have, I don't even, I could
have bought something good
with this". (laughs)
You know what I mean?
- What the fuck?
- (laughs) Like I feel
like, I'm not gonna lie.
When I was 15, I probably didn't
give any money to charity,
because I didn't have any-
- Well yeah, obviously.
- Well, most of us didn't have any money-
- When I did, though,
it was like, when my mum gave me a pound.
And she was like, you
know when it was like,
when you're in school
- Oh, the old clothes day.
Old clothes day, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'd give a pound, and be
like, "It's on me, it's on me".
(men laugh)
God.
- This is not from my mom.
I swear.
- Guys, guys, don't worry.
I'll break out the-
- We all got this
from our parents, right?
- Yeah, I got change, guys.
- That's just what I hated doing.
Like, I wish there was
some kind of system where,
why do I gotta be the
messenger for my mom's money?
(Joey snorts)
Why do I gotta
bring this shit in?
- What do you mean
the messenger?
- Like,
surely, can't you collect
this shit from my parents?
Why do I have to bring
in money from my parents?
You know, and-
- It's a pound.
You're not carrying a
fucking briefcase of cash.
- I'd just spend it, you know.
I just (laughs), I never did, actually.
- I knew people in my school
who'd just fucking spend it.
- I mean, there was plenty of good places.
In my town, there's a thing
called a pound bakery.
- Mm-hmm.
- Did you ever
have one of these?
- No.
Bregs?
- No, no.
It's even cheaper than Bregs.
- Oh, shit.
- You could get two pasties for a pound.
- What the fuck's a pastie?
- Oh yeah, a pastie is a
very British thing as well.
I've realized this after moving out.
- You don't know what a pastie is?
- Like a pastry?
- Well yeah-
- Kind of.
- Pastry, but it's got
like, there's a lot of meat
inside of it-
- Yeah.
It's got some meat, potatoes.
- So, let me tell you
the most popular fillings for pasties-
- Okay, yeah-
- Cheese and onion.
Which is a bunch of cheese and onion.
- Like okay, thank you.
- Like a beef pastie as well, right?
- There's a kidney and-
- Kidney...
- Kidney and steak?
- Yeah, yeah-
- Like a pie?
- Kind of, kind of but-
- Pastry-
- More pastry-
- I'm not a big fan
of pies, pies are a little
too thick, the crust.
They're really popular-
- Like a sausage roll?
- That's always there.
That's always one of them.
That's not really a,
that's a sausage roll-
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- And there'd be like,
my personal favorite was the
sausage, bean and cheese melt.
Which is just sausage, beans and cheese
shoved into a pastry-
- And melted, I assume.
- It's like, now that I think about it,
it's probably the closest thing you'd get,
not like, in terms of like,
cultural importance as like, an onigiri.
Like, a pastie is just
like a British onigiri.
- It's the British (laughs)-
- It is, isn't it!
It is!
I just like, realized that
as we were talking about it.
- The reason why it
became popular is because,
when they'd like, because
obviously coal mining
was a massive thing in the UK,
is that they needed food
that wouldn't go bad.
And they would literally put
these things in their pockets.
- Oh-
- And they would just eat them
in the mines.
- Right, right, right.
- And for some reason, we
decided that that was just great.
We should just-
- Now it's your onigiri, now.
- (laughing) Yeah, it's
the British onigiri.
Fuck jelly donuts!
- Well, you take two pastries,
which pastries are pretty
fucking filling things,
for one pound, and I was like,
"Holy shit, this is insane".
- That's pretty good.
- Yeah, two-
- And they taste good, right?
- Yeah.
They're really good shit.
- Oh shit.
- How were your school
dinners back in the day?
- Fucking dreadful.
(Garnt laughs)
I'd rather eat the mushroom
that Meilin pulled up.
(men laugh)
It was absolutely terrible.
The only thing that was
good was like, toast,
for some reason, tastes
really good at school.
And always, toast, did you ever have this,
the toast taste different?
Like, wildly different wherever you go?
- I mean like, it's the type
of bread they use, right?
- It's like, it's not even like,
I feel like, toast doesn't
even taste remotely the same-
- Because toast here
tastes completely different
to anywhere else.
- Yeah, but as well,
when you make toast at home,
it has a completely different taste,
to when you get toast at a restaurant.
Like, it's wildly different, I think.
It doesn't even taste like toast-
- Like, back in the day,
like fucking school dinners
were kind of like prison
food, almost, right?
You'd go in the fucking cafeteria,
there was always these, you know,
the lunch ladies, they'd
always look depressed as fuck.
And you'd come in with your tray,
and now that I think about it,
you kind of just felt like
you were in prison. (laughs)
- We didn't even have that.
We just had a cafeteria,
like we called it a tuck shop.
- A tuck shop, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys have tuck shops, right?
- No.
- What's that?
- What the fuck is a tuck shop?
- Now that's a very Australian
thing, I just realized.
So it's like, a tuck shop
in Australian schools,
is basically this booth.
You can go and just buy food items.
- Right.
- It's not even
a cafeteria, it's not even a room.
- It's a stall?
- It's like a stall.
Basically, because our schools didn't...
A lot of schools in Australia, I think,
don't really have full-on cafeterias,
because none of them are like,
big enough to have full-on cafeterias.
So like, the only experience of cafeterias
I ever had as a kid, was
watching the "Simpsons".
- (laughs) Okay.
- Like that was the closest
I ever got to a school cafeteria.
Because like-
- Australian schools-
- There are no schools, I
didn't know a single school
in my area, or in Australia
at all, that had that.
Like, school lunch in the cafeteria-
- This sub guy just
fucking drops off some shit
in his truck.
(Garnt laughs)
Here you fucking go, kids.
- Yeah, go for it kids.
- How about some fucking sausages?
Here you go.
- Yeah, you literally
just go to like, a stall kind of thing.
And there'd be like, a canteen lady there,
or the cafeteria lady.
It's just like, you just buy stuff.
- I just like, smooth talk them.
Or I used to always be
really, really fucking nice
to the cafeteria ladies, so
they'd give me extra food.
- Oh yeah, yeah, and
whenever my friends' mom
was the cafeteria lady, I'd be like,
"Hey, come on, come on.
Let me in, let me in.
Give me some of the back stock there".
- I would, no joke, I would literally be,
I'd be like, "That food was
amazing, that was fantastic".
(Joey laughs)
(men laugh)
- Seriously?
- Yeah!
Because-
- Compliments to the chef.
- Yeah, because I would literally,
I would always go back, I'd be like,
"Thank you so much, that was
great, that was fantastic".
(men laugh)
Because, right-
- Did the give you
anything for it?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
After a while of doing this,
they would like, make
specialized things for me.
- Wow.
- Because I would always,
my mates gave me so much shit for it.
Because they're like, "Why are you fucking
sucking up to them", I'm like,
"Well look at my fucking meal.
I'm eating like a king
today. Enjoy your slop."
They custom made the shit-
- Custom made!
- It's off this fucking line, bro.
- They're like, "Yo, Connor's rolling in.
Bring out the good shit".
- Bring out the good shit.
Bring out the-
- Bring out the three
course meal.
- They're about to serve me,
and the other one's like,
"No, stop, it's Connor".
- Do you know who this man is?
(men laugh)
- It's distinction!
They're like, so they used to make like,
so this is again, a really
fucking British thing.
Jacket potatoes, you ever heard of this?
- Jacket potatoes?
- Yeah, I know
jacket potatoes.
- Literally just like-
- It's a potato.
- It's a potato-
- With butter.
- You stab it a bunch, maybe
you cut it open a little.
You put butter in it.
Baked potato.
- Oh, baked potato.
All right.
- You wrap it up.
It's called jacket potato in the UK.
- It's just potato with butter.
- And they would just give
it to you, like just there.
And I was like, come on,
I'm better than this.
And I was like, "I know
you've got some chuter
in the back, there, I know
you've got some beans and cheese.
Can you put that shit all over it?"
So they would make like, normally
you'd get a jacket potato,
but, because I was very nice to them,
they would put like, tuna in there.
Which I fucking love,
beans and cheese as well.
And I would rock up like, "Yeah, boys.
I'm eating like a king today".
It was very good.
- You literally just like,
James Bond that shit.
You come up being like, "Connor?"
- No, the reason why I did
it is because I realized
that one of the other kids,
who was way older than me
got a bunch of really, it
looked like he always had,
like everyone else's
tray was peasant tray,
and this guy always had
a stacked fucking tay.
And I was like, "What is this guy doing?"
Because like, they don't
give you extra if you ask.
They just laugh at you.
So I was like, "Oh fuck, what's he doing?"
I watched him, and he was just
like, smooth talking them.
Just saying like, thank you a bunch.
(Joey laughs)
I was like,
who knows, all we had to
do was just say thank you
and be nice, and say a few words to them.
And they'd give you more.
- Wow.
- What was the best part
of the school dinner
you remember?
- I feel like I know
what you're gonna say.
- Because what reminds me of this-
- Are you gonna say like,
turkey Twizzlers or some shit?
- No, no, no, no.
What reminded me of this
was because we went to...
There's a local bar near us, and it's,
I don't even know how to
describe what the theme
of this bar is, right.
There's this bar that we go to that has
just, the most random assortment of foods
you could think of.
- It's all good though.
- It's all good, it's all great.
And so we order this, I can't
remember what we ordered.
But we ordered some dish.
And what comes out is the
fucking smiley potato chips.
(men laugh)
- I love those things!
- So good!
- They taste so god damn good.
- And I can't remember
what dish we ordered.
But I remember we came, it came out.
And like, the three of
us just reverted back
to being like, seven years old.
Being like, "Oh!"
- Oh!
- Sweet potato chips!
This is what it looks
like, if you didn't have it
wherever you grew up.
It's basically just the Funimation logo.
(men laugh)
- The Funimation logo with eyes.
- It's weird, because it has
a taste that is so unique.
- Because it's not fries-
- God damn good.
- It's not fries, it's not potatoes.
It's just got such a unique taste.
And I'm sure anyone who
didn't grow up with it
would think it tastes like shit.
- I could be a billionaire,
and I'll be like,
"Charles, heat up the
smiley faces, won't you?"
(laughs) Bring in the smiley faces.
- Ever since I saw those
at that restaurant,
I've been trying to find them.
- Dude, they're so good!
- Like, I can't find them anywhere.
Because they don't sell
them in supermarkets-
- We've gotta ask, what's your source?
- I'm like, "Wait" (laughs)-
- Who's your-
- Where'd you source these?
- Because I, it's so bizarre.
Because the restaurant,
I wouldn't call it posh.
But it's like-
- The decor is extremely nice.
Very, I'd say-
- Very homely, yeah.
- Yeah, it's very nice.
It's not-
- Bouquets everywhere.
There are fresh bouquets.
- So I just laughed, right?
Because they bring out this dish.
And they were just probably like,
"This is imported potato
from Britain, enjoy lads".
And I'm just thinking here,
"This is just school dinner
chips right here, man".
- This is 10 cents apiece.
(men laugh)
This is like currency
in elementary school.
(men laugh)
- Well yeah, those were
the one things I remember.
Like, that was universal.
In every school dinner
we had it in the UK.
Every kid remembers the smiley chips-
- Dead ass in primary
school, it was like currency.
Like, you would trade other
food items with people
for smiley-
- Yeah, I don't know.
I think it's phased out now.
Because school dinners, from
what I've heard in the UK,
are a lot more healthy
than they used to be.
- Oh, really?
- And that's because,
do you know Jamie Oliver?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I think back-
- Man is on a crusade.
- Yeah.
- Oh really?
- For like, healthy school dinners.
And apparently it worked.
I'm jealous, because I've seen
some of the school dinners
that kids get nowadays, and
man, they be eating good.
They be eating, they're
getting like a fucking
three course meal with roast
chicken and all that shit-
- What the fuck?
- I'm just like. (laughs)
- See, the fanciest thing
I had in my cafeteria was,
it was a chicken tender roll.
- Yeah-
- Which is literally
a bun with two chicken tenders in it.
$4 (laughs).
- Does anyone remember
bringing your own lunch?
- Yeah, I always did.
- Packed lunch.
- Yeah, that's what I
used to do for a while.
I can't remember why,
because I had school lunches.
And I had packed lunch for sometime.
I don't remember why I didn't,
but I remember, I used to trade.
Did you ever trade stuff
with the other kids?
- Yeah.
- Because your mum
put stuff in your box, and you're like,
"Well, it's not that I don't like this,
but that guy likes this
thing, and I wanna trade".
- I always did-
- I remember I used
to trade Kit Kat for cheese strings.
Because I like cheese string-
- Oh, cheese string!
I remember cheese string-
- That's the one
that you like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because I'm not being funny.
Obviously, I love Kit Kats.
But frankly, eating a
cheese string as a kid
is probably one of the
most enjoyable things.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- You know, still to this day,
I still really enjoy the process
of eating a cheese string.
I think it's very satisfying.
And I traded, always I traded my Kit Kat
for this kid's cheese string.
- (snorts) Why didn't
you just ask your mom
to get cheese strings?
- Well because I think,
actually...
This is gonna be big brain.
I think actually, that the cheese string's
actually more expensive.
- Oh really?
- Than the Kit Kats, and
the packs of Kit Kats
were pretty cheap-
- That makes sense, yeah.
- Because they were like the
branded cheese strings as well.
- Oh-
- They were like,
the cheese strings.
- Right, right, right.
- When I told my mom, I felt like,
I never saw her like, weirdly
upset about something.
I was like, "Mum, why
are you upset about me
trading cheese strings?" She was like,
"You could have told me,
why didn't you tell me?"
I'm like, "I didn't
think it was a big deal!
I'm out here hustling, mom, it's fine.
I got, it's fine, don't worry about it"-
- She's like, "You think we
can't afford cheese strings
in this house?"
- Wait, you told me
you don't like cheese string, I'm like,
"I like the hustle, it's fun, okay!
I like trading, I like it"-
- I'm a businessman, mom.
- (laughs) Mom, I read "Art of the Deal".
Come on, let me be.
I liked it, it was fun scouting out
what everyone else had, and you'd be like,
"Trade?
Trade offer?"
- Trade offer.
- Literally. (laughs)
I would go up to the kids
and be like, "Trade offer"-
- I receive cheese string.
- I receive-
- You receive Kit Kat.
- I would, I don't know, as a kid,
for some reason, I didn't have any qualms
about going up to a kid and
being like, "I like that.
We should trade, what do you think?"
- Oh yeah, of course.
I feel the only time you can do that,
and it's not weird, is when you're a kid.
- And then sometimes kid would be like,
I feel like they didn't,
they wanted the trade,
but they were skeptical as
to why I wanted to trade.
What's wrong with it?
What did you do to the Kit Kat?
Right?
- Yeah.
- I just want it, like, mm.
"I don't know, Conner, you've
got a reputation for hustling.
I don't know about that".
(Garnt laughs)
- I'll tell you, the kid
I was always jealous of
were the kids that had
the Dairylea Lunchables.
Because that looked so fun!
Because, Dairylea Lunchables.
It's basically like
Build-A-Bear, but for lunch.
- You've had a Lunchable.
- I've had a Lunchable.
But, it's-
- It's the pack
that comes with like, the
biscuit, the cheese, and the ham.
- Oh yes, yes, yes-
- You put up
your own like, little sandwich.
- Yep, yep.
- I don't know why.
As a kid, that just seemed so fun.
- And it is.
- But it was like,
expensive as fuck for a kid.
Those kids were eating good.
- That thing had like,
negative nutrition I think.
Pretty sure it actively
took it out of your body.
(men laugh)
Also, you know Lunchables,
I don't know if its the same brand.
It was Dairylea, though.
They do like, the dairy
dunkers, did you like those?
- Oh, what were they again?
- Oh was that like,
the chocolate sauce ones?
- They did have chocolate sauce.
But it was like-
- Oh, the cheese sauce one.
- There was cheese sauce ones,
which I really fucking love.
- Right.
- They were, yeah.
I think originally, they were chocolate.
Where it was like a biscuit,
bread kind of thing-
- It was like a biscuit, like
half a biscuit breadsticks,
and then the other half's like, chocolate.
- Yeah, yeah-
- We had those.
Yeah, we had those.
- Yeah, and then they
had a cheese version.
And then, they had this one-
- I've never heard of the cheese version.
- Yeah, it was pretty popular in the UK.
- Really?
- I loved,
fucking loved those things as a kid.
I fucking put those away.
And then, I was eating
them up until like, age 21.
Because they had a version where like,
it was like some herb stick or something,
and I really fucking loved it.
Like legit eating it until 21.
And they changed the
recipe, and I was like,
"You've lost a longtime"-
(men laugh)
It actually tasted like shit.
I'm like, "I don't know what happened".
- Wow.
- I wanted to email HQ
being like, "How fucking dead"-
- Did you change the flavor?
Did you change the recipe?
- Tell me changed the flavor.
Tell me my taste buds haven't changed.
This tasted like shit.
I'm not crazy.
- You guys ever had a food
product later in life,
that you just like,
couldn't believe that you'd
waited this long in life before you'd had
this one food product?
Because I'll tell you what-
- I was gonna say,
you must have a very specific-
- Yeah, you must have-
- I mean, I mean,
because thinking about it-
- Do you have this
super specific situation?
- Did you have this
- Because...
- (laughs) Because,
well I'll tell you mine, actually.
Because I didn't try
Nutella for the first time,
until I was 24.
- How did you avoid Nutella
for so long?
- Okay, because-
- Nutella's like, everywhere.
- Yeah, because I was a kid,
I wasn't allowed Nutella, right-
- Yeah, my parents wouldn't
let it in the house.
- Really?
- Because it's basically
just fucking chocolate, right.
It's just basically chocolate.
- It's actually worse
for you than chocolate.
- Is it? (laughs)
- Yeah, there's more sugar-
- That's understandable, yeah.
- So I just went my entire
life without trying Nutella.
I don't know how, but how
has Nutella been branded
as just this thing you
can spread on toast,
and people eat for breakfast?
Right, and that feels
like a cheat code to me.
You know, because I remember
trying it for the first time,
and I'm just like, "This
is the most amazing snack
I've ever tried in my life".
And it's just like, the fucking
gates of Babylon opened.
I'm just like, "Oh my God, I
have discovered God", right?
(men laugh)
- It literally goes on like, everything.
- Yeah I know!
- You open the jar, it just
starts to glow, like (gasps).
- My favorite thing, (sighs)
I can't remember which,
again, I forget this all.
But there's little a video
where they were like,
it was about this whole,
the deception of Nutella
being a breakfast product.
And there was this part in
it, where they go onto parents
who are feeding their kids
Nutella, and they're like,
"Do you know how much
sugar is in Nutella?"
They're like, "No".
And they tell them, they're
like, "There's a lot of sugar.
Like a lot", they're like,
"Oh my God, I had no idea".
(Garnt laughs)
And they look like, so dumbfounded.
Like, "What are you serious?"
The chocolate spread?
The pure, 100% chocolate
flavor that I'm spreading
on a piece of bread
twice is bad for my son?
You're kidding me.
It's just like-
- Surprised Pikachu face.
- It's literally, and they're, "Oh my God.
I've been feeding my kid
chocolate this whole time!"
It's like, "What did you think it was?"
No one thought it wasn't chocolate!
We all know that Nutella is chocolate.
Just because it's kind of liquidy,
like very viscous, you
think it just gets a pass?
- Yeah, why is it that
Nutella gets a pass,
and yet Cocoa Puffs is
like, no, no, no, no, no!
(Garnt laughs)
- Because branding, Joey.
Branding is powerful. (laughs)
- How did they get away
with this for so long?
I don't know.
Nutella fucking slaps, but I
knew as soon as I tasted it,
it's fucking unhealthy as shit.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- But it tastes amazing.
- Literally anyone who
knows what sugar tastes like
would be like, "I think
this is pretty bad".
- It's pretty bad, yeah.
- It's pretty bad for you,
I think, actually, you know? (laughs)
My parents would only let
me have it on holidays.
- Oh really?
- That's how taboo it was.
It was like, "This is for
special occasions only".
- No, I think my parents
let me have Nutella
like pretty much every
morning if I wanted it.
But then I very quickly was
like, "This is too much".
Like this is too much sugar.
Even for my eight year old body,
I know this is too much
sugar in the morning.
- Yeah, I'm just like,
now I just think, "Kids,
you're not allowed
to have ice cream for breakfast,
but Nutella, that's okay".
And I'm just like, to me, they're
on the same fucking level.
- You should put Nutella on ice cream.
- That sounds amazing.
- That shit slaps.
- Nutella flavored gelato-
- Nutella on some like,
fucking vanilla ice cream. (clicks tongue)
That shit slaps.
- I mean that's,
it's just a dessert, right?
- It is.
It's just chocolate!
(Garnt laughs)
It's literally just chocolate.
- [Garnt] It's just a bit
of naughty chocolate, right?
- It's ridiculous.
You know what's another
thing I fucking grew out of,
I think I just like grew out of all
viscous breakfast spreads.
- Viscous breakfast spreads?
- Ah yes, what's your favorite
viscous breakfast spread?
(men laugh)
- Like, Nutella-
- Viscous breakfast,
who on earth, no one has
ever described it like that.
- It the only way I could describe it.
- You literally, you could
have said breakfast spread.
You didn't have to put
whole viscous in there-
- No, no, no-
- Viscous-
- I'm pretty sure that's the first time
in the history of man
that those three words
have been put in the
same sentence together.
- This is like-
- No, no, that's-
- Alien, to the best of your knowledge,
describe what this spread is.
- I too love
this viscous breakfast spread, human.
- What is wrong-
(men laugh)
- No, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
I specifically used the word viscous,
because like, jam-
- I could feel someone
doing the fucking lawnmower
(imitates a lawnmower revving),
in his fucking head, trying
to form that sentence.
- No because,
because okay, I used the word viscous,
because jam, for instance-
- How are you gonna
talk about peanut butter and jelly, right-
- No, no, no, that too.
But like, jam for instance, right,
that's not viscous.
You know what I mean?
- Depends.
You can make it viscous-
- It doesn't stick
to the roof of your mouth
like Nutella does, right?
- I love a good fucking jam.
- But the thing is, is like,
not only did I grow out of Nutella,
but also peanut butter.
I used to fucking love peanut butter.
- I don't know a single person in the UK
who ate peanut butter as a child.
- Right, but like-
- No, no.
I didn't eat peanut butt either.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Because I ate it as a
child, but then after a while
it was like, I don't know,
I don't think I like this.
Just, the fact that
every time I take a bite,
and it just feels like I just
swallowed a mouthful of glue
is just like, honestly, it's viscous.
The viscous!
It's the viscosity of peanut
butter that I don't like.
- I think nine out of 10 people I know,
who have peanut butter is
just for catching mice.
(Joey laughs)
That's why I had it.
- Really?
- I only bought it because
apparently mice fucking love it.
- Well yeah, I don't blame 'em.
- I mean, I'm licking the floor.
So I mean-
(Joey laughs)
- They call me.
- I gotta.
God damn I got my-
- I'm just ready
for the Drake meme, like,
peanut butter and jelly sandwich?
I sleep.
Like, viscous breakfast spread?
Real shit. (laughs)
But yeah, I remember, because
I hadn't tried peanut,
that was another food
item that I didn't try
until later in life, was peanut butter-
- I've never had just
peanut butter on a sandwich
or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I remember trying
it for the first time,
and I was very underwhelmed by it.
It was like the most
five out of 10 food item
I've ever tasted in my life.
- What about its viscosity, though?
(Garnt laughs)
Doesn't that shit just
like, stick to your mouth?
- Okay, which kind of
spreads did you have?
Did you have like, the chunky spread,
or did you have like, the smooth spread?
- I mean, I went either or.
- I've never had a
spread of peanut butter.
- You've never had a
spread of peanut butter?
- I've only had Reese's cupcakes.
Which, yeah-
- I also hate the viscosity
of those.
- Well, I remember
the first time I-
- Do you just wanna
say viscosity?
- I love that word.
- I very much had a, like
the kombucha tea meme,
when I first tried the Reese's cupcakes.
And I was like, I had
it, and I was like, "Oh.
Oh! Oh?"
- I think the one thing
I don't look about Reece's cups is that,
again, the peanut butter
overpowers everything.
And it's like a certain-
- Is that the point?
I don't know if that's the point.
- I don't know if that's the point-
- There's like, something
about the peanut butter that I,
I think I just don't like peanut butter.
- Foreigners trying to
figure out American food.
Like, "What is going on here?"
- I think, I just
realized, like right now.
I just think I don't like
peanut butter. (laughing)
- Is it, okay Americans,
is it normal to feel like,
violently uncomfortable after eating
more than two of those cups?
Is that normal?
(Garnt chuckles)
Meiling, is that normal?
Does your stomach feel
really uncomfortable?
- How many Reece's cups can you eat?
- You can eat like a bunch?
- Yeah, right-
- You start to feel
like real uncomfortable, right?
There was no, they came
in a nice pack of three.
So I assumed I eat all three.
Oh you don't, fuck.
That is the biggest lie
America's ever told.
- That's a lie-
- You share.
- Share bags, my ass.
Why would they, why would they-
- I mean, it-
- My hand fit
so perfectly in it then?
- That's like saying,
"Oh, you can break off a Kit Kat,
and share it with another person".
No one fucking does that shit.
(Garnt laughs)
Just open it, and just eat it.
- Especially now, I don't want someone
with their fucking sweaty
hands snapping a Kit Kat.
The whole palm reaching over
the whole Kit Kat to snap it.
Because that's-
(Joey laughs)
what you have to do.
I don't trust a person who
tries to do it like that.
That's weird, you want a clean-
- Yeah, you want that, right?
- But I also don't want
your whole palm touching it.
That's a little too much palm.
So frankly, we'll just buy
our own Kit Kats, you know.
- Just eat the fucking Kit Kat.
- Or honestly, in the
packet, rip it in the packet.
Because you can do that-
- Oh yeah, you can.
- Big brain.
- That's too big brain.
- But sometimes you forget.
You've opened it up, and you're like,
"Fuck I can't wrap it back up".
- Grab the packaging, just wir. (laughs)
- You gotta do like, have
you seen the Kit Kat adverts?
Where you're like the foil wrapping,
and then you just like,
split it in the middle?
- What, with like a knife?
- No, no, no.
With your finger, you like,
it just splits perfectly.
Does this-
- Is your fingernail
long enough for that?
- No, it is!
Okay, so-
- Have you done it?
- No. (laughs)
- I've never done that.
- Did that advert stop
getting played or something?
- I've never split-
- I've never seen that.
- Oh my God, I gotta
fucking show you after the-
- I've never split a Kit Kat.
- You've never, what? (laughs)
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait-
- You have-
- No, I have not.
- How do you eat Kit Kats?
- Just fucking take it out
of the package and eat it.
- Okay, I have done that.
But I don't believe you
that you've never split-
- No.
Because the Kit Kats I always used to get
were like, the mini packets of Kit Kats.
So it was like, it would be in a bag-
- You tell me you've never had a thought-
- You've never had a single Kit Kat-
- You've never had a four bar Kit Kat?
- Yeah.
Yeah, and I just eat it.
- No.
You fuck off. No you didn't.
- Joey (laughs)-
- I think,
you must be lying-
- Wait, wait, wait, wait,
shut the fuck up, do you
just fucking bite that shit
without splitting it?
- Yeah.
- No.
- No Joey, no!
- No-
- I am true evil.
- No.
- I don't believe that you've
never cracked a Kit Kat apart.
- I don't do it on the
fucking regs, though.
- When are you eating Kit Kat?
Who the fuck's eating Kit Kat often?
- No, but like every
time I have a Kit Kat,
it's usually in like, you know,
two Kit Kats together, right?
The max is like, four in a row.
- Yeah, and you split it-
- No.
- Eat it one at-
- I literally just grab,
and just, do this.
- Don't!
No Joey, no.
(Joey laughs)
- Because like, the crumbs
get everywhere and shit.
- No, I just eat it in one go.
- No, it's such a mess.
Like, crumbs go everywhere,
the wafer falls.
The structural integrity has
been compromised, frankly.
- It doesn't matter,
because two seconds later,
it's all going in your mouth.
- Pretty sure society would crumble
if everyone did that, Joey.
(Joey laughs)
Jesus Christ.
(Garnt laughs)
- This is why we ran out of toilet paper
People like this.
- Gotta wipe up the Kit Kat crumbs-
- Is this an Australian
thing that I just don't-
- No, I know this is just a me thing.
- Well, has no one ever
shamed you about this
in your life, but there's no
way you went through school
eating Kit Kats like
that, and not got bullied-
- I never ate Kit Kats in school.
Kit Kats were a me thing, in my room.
- What's wrong with you, Joey?
- It's a fucking chocolate bar.
Who cares?
Does it say on the packaging,
"Must crack one at a time
in order to eat successfully"?
No, it doesn't.
- Well, it's like
only drinking beer via like, shot gunning.
(men laugh)
It's like, yeah okay,
it's a one off, I get it.
But that shouldn't be
your primary go-to method
of drinking a beer out of a can, you know?
Like, stabbing a hole in the bottom
and fucking drinking it.
That shouldn't be your go-to method.
You know what I mean?
It's like that, it's like-
- It's nothing like that.
What are you on?
- It is like that.
- Oh my God.
- You're literally
making it harder to eat.
- I'm not, I'm making it easy,
because I'm saving my fucking palms
from getting all chocolatey by doing this.
- (sighs) Oh, God.
- I just like,
open it up halfway, and then
grab it by the packaging,
and then just fucking do this-
- There's a reason there are
crevices in the Kit Kat, Joey.
There are reasons for it!
It's literally designed into
the fucking food product!
It's designed to be eaten
a certain way, Joey!
- Look, sometimes I wanna break the rules.
All right? (laughing)
Fuck society.
- Do you ever just like,
wake up and remember
that Toblerone took out like 50%
of the fucking chocolate?
(Garnt giggles)
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just can't believe
they did that still.
I still cannot-
- Do you know Toblerone?
- Yeah.
- You've seen the modern ones?
- No.
- You know how the gaps used to be very,
I would argue, perfect.
You know, when the one went to up,
the next-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you could easily just do that right?
- Yeah, it's not like that.
- Yeah, like with Kit Kats,
Joey.
- No, no.
Toblerone-
(men laugh)
Listen, Toblerones are fucking massive.
They're like this big.
I'm no gonna fucking (gagging).
(men laugh)
- I have done that, I have done that.
I bought too many at the airport.
I had to start, and you know,
just getting a little wild and...
- Just fucking deep throating-
- Deep throat a Toblerone.
(men laugh)
- Have you not seen what they look like-
- (laughs) Toblerone
deep throat challenge.
- Oh my God, Mister Beast,
"Who can deep throat
the most Toblerones for $10,000"?
- But yeah, so because,
I was out of the UK
by this point, right?
But, so Toblerone, you know
what a Toblerone look likes,
looks like, it looks like this, Chads.
Not Chad, fucking-
- Chads! (laughs)
- Fuck, man.
I've been watching too much Twitch.
But so, I think one year they just decided
to make less Toblerones.
Or, they made the gaps-
- So this is the
original Toblerone.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm used to.
- Right, right.
And your gonna fucking cry.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] This is it now.
- [Garnt] Yeah, so that can't be real.
- That's real.
- That cannot be real.
- That's real, that's real!
- Yeah, that is real.
That is real.
- Are you shitting me?
- No, that's what it is.
- Why are the Toblerones
social distancing?
- I don't know.
(men laugh)
- It's like, "We're too close".
- I just-
- Give me some room.
- Sometimes I just wake up at night,
and I just remember they did that.
- Oh no.
- They got away with it.
And they still are expensive-
- Did they get away with it?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure like, they-
- I haven't heard
of recent memory, of people
buying Toblerone. (laughs)
- I'd like to think that
even like, you know,
that this plummeted their stock.
But I don't think it did.
- Pretty sure people
rioted because of this.
That's like the impression I got-
- I mean, if I'd known
about it back in the day,
I would've rioted.
- Because I remember, it was like,
it was just when I moved out of the UK,
because I can't remember
if I was living here.
When did they do this?
Was this when you were living in the UK?
- Yeah, it was when I was living in the-
- So I must have just moved
to Thailand or something.
And I remember moving to Thailand,
one day I wake up, and
my entire fucking feed
is just people complaining
about the Toblerones-
(Joey laughs)
- It's just,
it's like they didn't even try and hide
how much chocolate they were taking away.
Like just fill it with some shit.
Make it less tasty.
Like don't ruin the,
because one of the best
things about a Toblerone
is that you get so God
damn much chocolate-
- Yeah.
- You get a fuck ton.
Like arguably, one piece
of Toblerone is too much.
- That shit lost you.
- I think actually, eating a
single piece of the triangle
is actually uncomfortable.
It's almost too much-
- It is too much chocolate-
- That's always the best part,
because it's good shit too.
It tastes great.
- It's the perfect amount
where you're like, "I don't
even wanna go for another one.
I'll save it for the next day".
- Yeah, I also learned as well,
because I used to always snap it away.
- Yeah.
- Did you do that
as well?
- Yeah, yeah.
I did that.
- Yeah.
- But then, the way that I actually do it,
is to push it inward, and it snaps easy.
- Oh, like that?
- Yeah, you snap it in,
and it just breaks off.
But now you'll never get to experience it-
- Yeah, no. (laughs)
- The design
is fundamentally changed, so-
- Wait.
How are you supposed to
snap the new ones now?
- I don't know.
It's fucking-
- With a fucking knife?
- Smack it against the
concrete or something?
I don't know.
- (imitates a cutting serrated
blade) Cut it with a knife.
- I mean, you don't need to snap it.
It will probably just like...
It's so long that it'll
probably just break under the-
(Joey giggles)
- Yeah, honestly.
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God, why do they do this to,
why are they masking my boy like that?
- I couldn't believe they did it.
I'm still like, I wake up in a cold sweat-
- How have I like, just
found out about this?
- I'll tell you what-
- I don't know
if it's the UK only or not-
- I'll tell you
what I think is an underrated
snack, chocolate snack.
Terry's Chocolate Orange.
I fucking love Terry's Chocolate Orange-
- Oh-
- Do you have
Terry's Chocolate Orange?
- I don't, but I've heard of it.
- They have it in America.
- They have it in America?
- Yeah, yeah, they have it in America.
- Yeah, so it's basically
just a chocolate orange.
But the fucking best part of it
is that it's literally an
orange that you have to like,
smack, and you eat a little chunk-
- It's the shape of an
average sized orange.
- And I don't know what it is-
- Solid chocolate.
- Yeah.
It's just a ball of solid chocolate,
that you eat like an orange, right?
And I don't know what it is.
Like, they have the Terry's
Chocolate Orange bars,
and I don't know what it is
about playing the minigame
of like, fucking smacking the chocolate
and peeling it yourself, it
just tastes so much better,
and so much more satisfying-
- It's because you're
working for it. (laughs)
- I love just smacking it
against my concrete wall
in my home, just fucking (grunts).
(men laugh)
Who wants a piece?
(Garnt laughs)
Who wants a piece of
Terry's Chocolate Orange?
And it's always really cheap as well.
They always go on offer for like, a pound.
So you've got like, way too much chocolate
for really cheap, somehow.
It was yeah-
- Wait,
does it have like,
actual orange in it, or?
- No, it's like orange flavor-
- It's like a
orange chocolate flavor.
- Right, right, right.
- Really nice, though.
Really like it, I don't
really like orange flavor.
- Because I think-
- It's very-
- Because I think my aunt,
I think the only reason why I
know about chocolate orange,
because like, my aunt used to
hand make chocolate orange,
but actually get slices of orange,
and like, coat it in
chocolate, and then like...
- Actually I've just figured out
what fucking Australians
get patriotic about.
- What?
- For some reason,
Tim Tams.
- Hell yeah!
- Tim Tams.
- Mid as fuck, Australians.
- Fuck you.
(men laugh)
- I think of the bourbon
biscuits (indistinct), you know?
- I don't know, I like-
- Every Australian I've met
has actually like, picked up Tim Tams.
So like, extreme levels, right?
- It's the only like, good snack we have.
(men laugh)
- Debatable, debatable.
- I mean, it just goes to show the quality
of the rest of our snacks, right?
(Garnt laughs)
I don't know, man, like it's good.
Don't get me wrong.
But like, Tim Tams or a bar of Toblerone?
I'll take the Toblerone.
- Yeah, yeah.
- To be honest, like there
are better snacks out there.
But Tim Tams is just so
readily available in Australia.
Like, anywhere you go,
that it's just like,
it's comfort food, basically.
- Yeah.
I mean, I feel like, I remember I tried it
for the first time,
and I feel like we have
some very similar-
- Yeah, we have
very similar products in the UK.
- Isn't Penguins kind of similar as well?
- Little bit, yeah.
- Penguins are great, though.
- Yeah, Penguins are great.
- Yeah.
What else do we have in the UK?
Oh, Jaffa Cakes.
- Oh, Jaffa Cakes, yeah, yeah.
- What do you think about Jaffa Cakes?
- Pretty shit.
- Oh okay, good, good, good-
- What are Jaffa Cakes, again?
That sounds familiar.
- Sponge cake with-
- Orange?
- Orange jam-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, we have
those in Australia too, yeah.
- It's pretty gross.
- They're all right.
- They have horrible shelf life.
Those things go bad really fast.
- Really?
- Yeah.
And like, you know-
- The only time
I ever ate them was at my
Grandma's place, though.
- The packet is big
enough where you kind of
have to do it in one sitting.
Because if you open the
bag, they go bad in one day.
So, if you buy them for yourself,
you gotta commit to-
- It's definitely like,
a home party snack, right?
- Yeah, you gotta-
- It's, whenever you go to any gathering,
or any kind of camping trip or something,
everyone always brings
out the Jaffa Cakes.
And I never understood why.
Because it's the middest snack in England
in my opinion, and for some reason
people think think I want
a piece of that. (laughs)
- What do you mean-
- I like the taste of it.
I think it's nice, but after I have two,
I'm like, "You know what, I'm
good for the next five years".
I don't want anymore.
(Joey laughs)
I'm fine.
(Garnt laughs)
Like, I enjoy it though.
I mean-
- That's how I feel
about Kinder Eggs.
- Oh, I fucking love Kinder Eggs.
- Kinder Eggs are great.
- But I have like, two,
and I'm like, "This is so much sugar".
I'm about-
- Kinder Bueno bars
are amazing.
- Kinder what?
- Kinder Bueno, oh.
Those are fucking great.
Those are great.
- Oh dude,
just bars full of the
Kinder, they're bueno.
- Oh God.
(men laugh)
- It's just Kinder.
It's really fucking good.
- Oh like, Kinder Eggs
in a bar-
- They're hazelnut as well.
- Yeah, the hazelnut ones are amazing.
- I'll bring you some when I go home.
- Do you have Aero in Australia?
- No-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We do.
- We do?
- Yeah, yeah, the really
like, fluffy chocolate,
not fluffy, but the really
like, bubbly chocolate-
- Bubbly chocolate.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
We have those, yeah.
They're pretty good.
- Yeah.
I don't know, I really, really
fucking like Aero, right?
But then I've just realized they're like,
selling me air. (laughs)
Because-
- It's the equivalent
of like, a pack of chips,
and 60% of it is air-
- But I just like how-
- Some people want like,
the light flavor-
- Yeah, I do like
the light flavor, right?
But it costs the same amount
as every other chocolate bar. (laughs)
- Would you like some chocolate air?
(men laugh)
- You know, sometimes,
when you buy the expensive chocolate,
like Lindt, or Lindor, or
whatever the fuck they are-
- Lind.
- Lind, whatever it is, I don't know.
- The Swiss chocolate?
- Yeah.
- You know,
sometimes you eat one, and you're like,
"Ah, it's good, it's good.
But do I really want like, 10?"
Like, it's not a chocolate you eat 10 of.
- Yeah, that's what I've noticed
about expensive chocolate.
Is like, you eat one, and
you feel like you've just
ate 10 chocolate bars in
this one fucking chocolate-
- Yeah, and then you're like, "Great.
I paid 50 bucks for these 10
chocolates, like this is..."
(men laugh)
- Time to give them away, I guess.
- It's like, "Fuck, what do I do now?
I don't really wanna eat these anymore".
- Yeah.
- That's why I like chocolates.
That you could eat so much of it.
(Joey laughs)
It's like,
it's so good.
Like, you never get bored of it.
Like Dairymilk, I never
get bored of that shit-
- I just can't even really eat
a lot of chocolate anymore.
- No, no me neither.
- Yeah.
- But Big Macs?
Yeah, hell yeah I can.
- Oh dude, I can smash
a Big Mac back everyday
if I want to.
- McFlurry?
Fuck yeah.
- Yeah, I don't know.
Ice cream is, I think my
love has grown for ice cream.
- Really?
- As I get older.
But my love for chocolate has gone down.
I don't know why.
- I think my-
- Ice cream is pretty MVP, though.
- Yeah, I think my love for
chocolate and ice cream's
just kind of gone down recently.
I don't know, my love for sweet things
has definitely gone down.
- Yeah.
- You're already sweet enough, Joey.
- Aw.
- It's not gonna (laughs).
- I definitely do like my
savory and saltier stuff better.
- Yeah, because for me,
I think a lot of people say
you have a second stomach
for dessert, I don't have a
second stomach for dessert-
- That's bull shit. (laughs)
- I'm just like, if I
have space in my stomach
for more food, then I'm
gonna eat more food.
- Yeah, right?
- Right?
- Right, I mean if there
is a tiramisu available,
I will always make room for a tiramisu-
- Okay, to be fair, if
a tiramisu comes out,
I'm smashing that shit back.
- I love tiramisu-
- Yeah that's,
it has to be my favorite cake.
What's your favorite cake?
- I don't know.
- This is like
asking an alien, name
your favorite celebrity.
- (laughs) I guess-
- The human on the TV
is my favorite-
- I guess,
if not like, the default chocolate cake,
then probably red velvet.
I fucking love red velvet-
- Red velvet is good cake-
- Red velvet is probably
the only other cake
that I like to eat, other than chocolate.
- Red velvet is very good.
- I can't eat a chocolate cake anymore.
It's just way too heavy now.
- Yeah, it depends.
Like, I never eat a chocolate cake-
- Getting old, boys-
- I could never eat
a chocolate cake after a meal.
I just, sometimes I just
get a random craving
for a chocolate cake.
- Right.
- Like for me, I don't really
eat as much chocolate anymore,
but sometimes I just get this
random craving for sweets.
And you know when you fucking,
you know when you're
hungry, and you feel like
you could eat everything, right?
And so, when I get this chocolate craving,
I buy like fucking,
(laughs) I fucking like,
buy 10 different types
of chocolate bars, chocolate
ice cream, chocolate cake,
I'm just like, "I'm fucking craving this.
I'm hungry enough to eat everything".
I have one bite of the chocolate cake,
and I'm just like, "Okay, I'm done now.
Fuck, I've made a massive mistake".
(Joey laughs)
Because I just have
a table full of chocolate in front of me
that I know I don't wanna eat anymore.
- God.
- But,
yeah I'm not really,
I'm not a dessert guy.
Are you a dessert guy?
- I mean, I prefer the main.
But sometimes, some places have like,
really good desserts,
and it makes you be like,
"Okay, hold up"-
- Could you get the,
have you ever been-
- Dessert's got a point.
- Have you ever been
to like, cake buffets?
- Is that, wait what, it's a thing?
- What is that?
- Oh, okay.
- Where, where is this?
- In Japan.
They're fucking everywhere, yeah.
- What, where?
- Yeah.
There's one really good
one I went to in Harajuku,
where it's like, (laughs)
it's literally like a
sushi train of cakes,
of like, tiny little cakes.
- How many can you have before
you start becoming sick?
- I had like four, and then I was done.
But like, some of my female friends
can have like, you know
10, 15 of these cakes-
- Jesus Christ.
- It's like, man.
You guys are built different.
- Real food?
Nah, sweet shit please.
- Sweet shit.
Yeah but-
- I like cupcakes.
Cupcakes are nice.
Something about a muffin
or a cupcake that I-
- I don't think I've had a cupcake
in like, five years (laughs).
- Just a muffin, I just like muffins.
Most of them are pretty easy.
- Muffins.
- Pretty good size.
- What is it about muffins
that are very British?
- I think it's very American, I'd say.
- Yeah, I think it's more American-
- When I think a muffin, I think British.
- Maybe the English muffin,
is what you're thinking of.
- Oh, could be, could be.
- Yeah, because I feel like,
definitely with dessert,
dessert culture is way stronger in Asia
than I feel when I was living in England.
Because I didn't, until
I moved to Thailand,
or until I went to Thailand,
I didn't know the concept
of just like, a dessert bar.
Where it's just a restaurant
that just specifically
serves desserts, that's
just not a thing in England-
- There's some.
- Like what?
- What was it, like Casper's
or whatever it's called?
- What the fuck is Casper's-
- The ghost?
- Yeah.
(men laugh)
A big chain I saw everywhere.
It was like a dessert thing.
But it was like, really tacky.
I didn't really like the look of it.
- Yeah like, the only kind
of, dessert oriented places
that I find in England now are just,
they are marketed as Asian
dessert places, right?
And that only started
cropping up more recent,
in the more recent times.
- Yeah, I guess I'm not a
fan of how fucking bright
and loud dessert places are.
I feel like I'm, do you know what I mean?
- Almost exclusively white as fuck-
- They're always like,
really pastel colors,
or really bright colors,
and I just feel like,
"Fuck I'm in"-
- You go blind
when you walk into one, right?
- I'm like, I wanna just get a dessert,
not be visually attacked-
(Joey laughs)
By all these fucking colors.
(Garnt laughs)
Do you know what I mean?
And I feel like I'm in the wrong place
when I go into there, because I feel like
I'm too British for this, I'm too sad.
I can't be in here-
- I just hate the fact
that like-
- It's horrible.
I can't stand it-
- All of the walls
are just white as fuck, and
they blast the light on.
And I'm like, "Oh God, it's 2 P.M.,
why are the lights on in here?"
Jesus Christ-
- When you use light mode.
- Yeah. (laughs)
It's like, oh!
(men laughs)
- Just depends on the place, yeah?
When you get different types of lighting
and walls, whatever
the fuck, I don't know.
- Do you ever, are you one
of those people who like,
care about the mood of a restaurant?
- Yeah, yeah-
- The lighting,
and stuff like that?
- Definitely helps,
with, get a feel for what
the owner wanted, right?
- Yeah, I didn't start to care about it
until kind of,
I would say like, my mid twenties.
- Yeah, they gotta build the atmosphere
before you even sit down, right?
Like they gotta get you
understanding the vibe,
what the food-
- Yeah because,
before when I was a fucking
uni student or something,
it's not just restaurants.
I didn't care about the bar
vibe, you know what I mean?
Like, to me, does it serve food?
Is it cheap, can I eat it?
- Yeah, true.
- That's all I cared about, right?
But like, as I grew older,
I'm just like, "Damn"-
- [Connor] Life's too short
to waste on shit places-
- Like, the vibe in the
place can really effect
if I'm enjoying my meal
or drink as much as usual.
And I don't know if something switched
into my brain or something. (laughs)
- But there's a part of me that's like,
I feel if a restaurant
has a really nice mood,
or a mood that is fitting
and is comforting,
then it almost sometimes
blinds you to the fact
that the food might not be
as good as you think it is.
- Oh no, I mean there's
plenty of times where
it sets up high expectations,
and the food comes out
and it's-
- It's like, E.
- It's so disappointing, right.
Because especially in Japan, right,
because I feel like especially in Japan,
every place has a unique vibe.
Every restaurant you go to looks amazing.
It has a unique selling point.
But that isn't always,
this isn't always, that doesn't
always equate to good food.
Or it just doesn't always
equate to amazing food.
- Weirdly enough, it's like
kind of the opposite in Japan.
Where like, the shittier
the place looks usually,
the better the food is.
Especially when it comes to ramen-
- Yeah, I was gonna say ramen-
- Like family-owned restaurants
and stuff like that-
- If the sign is falling apart,
then the ramen place is
probably pretty good.
(men laugh)
- Because why are you gonna give a fuck
about how it looks,
just eat the damn food.
- Or like, because that's how
I feel about Thai food, right?
Because I very rarely eat
in a Thai restaurant here.
And that's because, for me, growing up,
or not growing up, but
whenever I go to Thailand,
some of the best food would
be street food, right.
So that to me, was the best kind of,
comfort food that I would find.
And to me I'm like,
it's only when I'm like, really,
really missing Thai food,
and really craving it,
that I actually go out
and go to a restaurant.
But most of the times, I cook
it myself, because it's...
To me, it's like comfort food.
There's something comforting about it.
And it's like, the same with Japan,
where you go to a ramen shop,
if it looks like a high
class, prestigious ramen shop,
probably doesn't taste as good
as the run-down, family
made ramens, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, and (sighs).
Yeah, I guess.
- Wrap it up there.
- I guess we'll just wrap it up there.
- Jump right into the ending.
- Jump right into these patrons.
- Oh my God, wonderful patrons.
- Look at all of them.
- Goodness gracious.
- I bet they eat their Kit Kats correctly.
- Yeah, I bet they do.
(Joey laughs)
I bet they don't use viscous spread-
- I'm gonna get so much shit for that.
- Spreadable breakfast, viscous saliva.
- I think you're talking about
viscous breakfast spreads,
all right. (laughs)
- Jesus Christ.
- Hashtag viscous breakfast spread-
- (laughs) Viscous breakfast-
- It's like a tongue twister.
But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then make sure to go
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter,
meme us on the sub Reddit,
and you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- And yeah, that's pretty much it.
Hope you enjoyed yet
more hot takes for food.
This episode, we got like
a bunch today (laughs)-
- Hot takes and tangents, the episode.
- (laughs) And I guess
we'll see you all next time.
- [Hosts] Bye.
(relaxed music)